you can't say we're the modern day
philosophers were the ones putting the
truth out there in the world we're the
ones changing the world we're the ones
holding the mirror up to the powerful
people and then on the same level go why
are they canceling us for what we say
you said you're important you said
you're changing the world well if I was
someone in power I'd sure just want to
silence those [ __ ] that are
saying the real if you're that important
say we're not important at all and we
could say whatever the [ __ ] we want I
value saying what the [ __ ] I want so
treat me like a clown I don't give
100 shots welcome to the show thank you
what's happening man chilling man very
good I just missed you in the UK when
you were over there what do you make of
it uh I liked it I actually had a good
yeah I had a good time over there it was
cool we got to you know do some cool
interviews and uh I actually got to hang
out in London I haven't really hung out
in London before I didn't like do the
whole Pub thing I like the pub thing do
you not think you have an equivalent
over here it's different it's different
like Pub for Pub's sake is not we need
another excuse and I think that's why we
have like sports almost every night of
the week so it's like we can go to the
bar to watch a sport not just for a hang
yeah like just going to drink feels
wrong here
you know what I mean like I'm going to
the bar to drink like just that yeah
yeah to meet anybody maybe England but
mostly drink yeah doesn't that feel
I don't know man it's part and parcel if
the the British culture right this is
one of the problems they have with
shutting down of pubs that they're
saying it's disconnecting people from
each other yeah people are becoming more
isolated yeah so you spent a good bit of
time with true Geordie Brian
Free Brian well dude I want to talk
about that because I think he's
converting to Islam did you know that
did you get this is breaking news Brian
is actually converting to Davidson is
now Jewish yep and Brian through jordi's
converted to US Ryan is converting to
Islam yeah he had to give up the
foreskin
did you know that no he's a heavy price
to pay I imagine he's got a master I
don't know how heavy buddy you know what
I mean yeah Brian do you think Brian's
got a big big foreskin yeah yeah there's
no all four skins yeah it's just 90
foreskin it's like a soft it's like a
sock with a tennis ball in it
shout out to Brian man yeah so I I
thought it was very interesting because
you guys do these sort of intros to the
beginning of your pods where it's like a
a rant like a bit yeah for maybe a
minute or two minutes
and you guys have said some during those
that I I can't believe gets put on the
internet what was interesting about
watching Brian is he said something that
could have been a bit taken straight out
of one of your intros yeah right and he
got smashed for it Jim shark dropped him
PokerStars dropped him got banned for a
while on Twitch yeah
is there like a special button that
people need to be able to press that
lights up and says I'm doing a comedy
bit because he's not a comedian yeah but
he dips in and out of Comedy yeah and
because of that it's like he gets judged
by the same criteria that a normal
Creator does but tries to do the stuff
that comedians do do you know what I
mean it's like people that cross both
thresholds they're kind of they're in a
bit of a tough bind because they're
going to be looked at and it's like well
that wasn't a joke that was actually his
true [ __ ] whatever coming out yeah it
almost benefits every podcaster to do
stand up once
so you can say you're a comedian
so you've got the Canadian card yeah
just do it one time and then say you're
a comedian and then just say more or
less whatever you want because like
Comics were like
how do I say it it's only it's like if
you see somebody dressed in like a
provocative manner right and they're
your school teacher you're like what the
[ __ ] but if you saw like a stripper
dressed in that way you'd be like oh
she's really conservative when she's not
tripping right so I think that's what
it's like being a comedian where it's
like you expect me to say even crazier
[ __ ] so if I made the joke that he made
nobody would give a [ __ ] but I think
with a lot with Brian I think you expect
him to be very serious
like he's serious about a lot of [ __ ]
even though he's [ __ ] hilarious like
he was hilarious on our I don't know if
you saw all right yeah but that
[ __ ] is funny so yeah it's a
shame man it's a shame yeah I wonder how
do you create that kind of protection I
always you know my thing is I'm gonna
ride for the jokes my loyalties are the
jokes I know he was making a joke there
was clear misdirect he was playing off
of stereotypes that we all know exists
and um yeah I thought it was funny I
don't know if he has like a hatred in
his heart for for Muslims I think he is
a hatred it's hard for Andrew Tate do
you know what I'm saying but like if
Andrew take converted to Judaism then he
would have a joke about Jews right yeah
exactly like he'd say open it with like
my Dark Twisted Fantasy or whatever like
he would have something busting balls so
it's not about the religion it's just
about punishing this guy that he doesn't
like um
yeah yeah that's what I would say so
yeah I defend him but I also understand
these Brands they're looking out for
themselves right they don't really care
about him they care about his audience
and then once he becomes too radioactive
for them to make money why are they
going to keep giving him money now he's
got to remember that next time he does
business with a brand because if they
come back later and he continues to have
the biggest show and blows the [ __ ] up
and let's say he becomes you know the
the Rogue I guess maybe he's already the
Rogan of UK but let's say he is the
biggest [ __ ] platform then Jim shark
could come back and be like hey we'd
really like sponsorship and go [ __ ]
yourself you left me when I was in a
dark time so now I'm not going to
continue to promote your brand so that's
what I would do with him I would just
keep on getting bigger and then remind
every one of those companies ain't [ __ ]
well that was the interesting Insight I
learned from you that a lot of people
believe there is this Grand conspiracy
everybody is Unified together in this
way to try and take people down what you
said it's it's individuals it's
individual actions this guy's got a new
house that he basically can't afford the
mortgage on and a kid that's going to a
new private school and blah blah blah
wife expect a new car every so often
yeah and he goes I'm going to lose my
[ __ ] job yeah the incentives are
aligned for individuals to act in a way
which makes it look like a coordinated
conspiracy from the outside yeah that's
not to say that there aren't [ __ ]
like overlords out there that are trying
to coordinate certain things I'm sure
there are yeah but I do think that the
simplest solution is individual people
terrified about losing their job yeah
looking out for themselves 100 even
even though situations where we think
they're overlords a lot of times is the
people under them doing what they think
the overlords would like
like I remember I used to go there was
like a few like Fox News shows that were
like funny like they were actually funny
shows right and um they would have
comedians on you can kind of say
whatever and I remember going there and
I remember like times like like my
material would like skew a little bit
more conservative I remember reflecting
on going like wait a minute am I just
trying to say the thing that would win
in this environment and I had to check
myself and in that moment I was like oh
wow if I was an employee of this company
of course I'm gonna do the things that I
think my boss likes I'm gonna behave in
a way that you're being influenced just
skewed a tiny little bit we're humans we
like to be rewarded bro is this such a
thing as a joke that goes too far
yeah to everybody everybody's got a
limit but is there such a thing like
objectively as a joke that's too much
could you write a joke that would be so
much that it shouldn't be allowed on the
Internet or it shouldn't be allowed to
be published is it funny
yes no then there's not if it's funny if
everybody's laughing then then no
like you're laughing like I mean that's
the thing I learned in my career is
basically like in order for me to get
away with the most [ __ ] up jokes that
I want to make I got to do it right to
the people I'm talking about
so if I'm doing a joke I don't want to
do any black jokes with no black people
in the room I want there to be black
people in the room and I want to be
doing the joke to them because if
they're laughing you can't be offended
on their behalf and it's usually
white people offended on behalf of
non-white people right but if you see
the black people laughing now you got to
shut up with your offense right so what
I kind of realized that and I'm very
fortunate I got this you know very
diverse audience so I can talk about all
these different things to those people
and it's not just a bunch of white
people in the room making fun of
minorities which feels weird even if the
jokes are funny yes like there could be
a hilarious joke about Asians but if
there's no Asians there it's like all
right what's going on bro does it feel
weird talking about your friend behind
his back while he's not there I don't
even like talking about black [ __ ] on
the podcast without Alex so Alex one of
my co-hosts on flagrant like when he's
there it's way more comfortable talking
about black [ __ ] right because there's a
black dude at the window into the black
world yeah yeah he could be like okay
this is now I can see why people are
upset or if he's laughing you know that
it's silly it's still kind of fun yeah
it just makes it better yeah I know what
I mean or even gay stuff like without
Mark I don't want to talk about gay [ __ ]
do you know what I mean like he doesn't
know he's gay but he is
you know so that's why Mark is there so
we have some gay representation you know
what I mean just sitting in the middle
of two guys the way he likes it is it
listen you don't get monkey pox one at a
time guys you know that's a group
activity
shout out to the gays right with was
that a thing in England monkey pox
um did it come over here
no no it probably didn't no no England
no that just wait oh yo you gays in
England are soft
stepping up
Step It Up New York gays are the hardest
gays on the planet like we have New York
gays
they're okay
they're gay they're gay the way I would
be gay how
dick all the time bro
like like everybody was shocked that
this monkey box thing was like a problem
I don't know if you heard about it yeah
yeah yeah okay okay because the what's
the guy's name fauci fauci basically
came up and he was like
you know the way it's getting
transferred or whatever what did he say
exactly it's like [ __ ] I don't know how
he said he was getting drunk he was
getting transferred through butt sex
yeah but it's a specific type it was gay
orgies
uh yeah exactly okay yeah so
you know stop your orgies I'll do more
and then get immunity natural immunity
if you want I don't care what I'm trying
to say is like the places in the world
that have gay populations that weren't
getting monkey sex I don't think that
you're taking advantage of being gay
[Music]
the canary in your coal mine is have you
got monkey box on that Canary in a coma
it sounds like some gay [ __ ] bro that's
what I just said okay that's what I mean
that's a good pun when it comes to when
it comes to the brine thing to just like
think about that yeah
do you have stricter rules as your
platform grows
or is it just the fact that you're under
more scrutiny I think you just gotta be
funnier
the the rule would be be funnier and
when you're taking those shots make sure
that they but what about outside of that
what about if it's just someone
generally not necessarily a comedian not
trying to make a funny joke online as
your platform grows and there's more
people watch your stuff yeah do you need
to be more careful about the things that
you're saying especially in a way
depending on which like for example I
don't tweet anymore like I get all these
like my drafts are crazy like one day
between the delete oh man one day I
don't even delete it I don't even let it
out there I just type it in so I know
the thought is there and then that [ __ ]
goes right to the Dress if somebody
hacks my Twitter one day someone at
Twitter is going to press the wrong
button and unleash all of your drafts I
got to be on elon's good side I gotta
stop talking [ __ ] about Elon bro because
because he could release all my drafts
what do you think Elon hero or villain
that's pretty split halfway at the
moment the idea that like he could
figure out spaceships and not Twitter
like Twitter isn't like a hard thing
like have you ever met someone in Tech
like they're not the best like
socializing human beings do you know
what I mean like it the fact that they
could figure out socializing like have
you seen them talk to each other like
Zuckerberg has to like be reminded to
Blink right like his eyes dry out he's
like oh I like MMA I like surfing blink
okay there you go right it's like so so
it's like there's there's these aren't
the people that are good at socializing
and they figured out apps around
socializing
Elon can figure out how to just write
something and post it it's not that
difficult
so if I have no question he's going to
figure out it's going to be better
they'll have a billion users they'll
find out a way to monetize it it'll be
easy but is he doing it for the right
reasons in your opinion
yeah because that's the question right I
don't know but in my opinion yeah I
think I I would agree like it's well
what's the right reasons I I might have
a different right reason than you for me
it would be to if he cares about Free
Speech it would be to open up
Communication online yes that's my
opinion I think that's part of it but I
think it there's other parts what are
the bones I think if you're a
billionaire you need in some sort of
like news apparatus to protect yourself
like there's a reason why Microsoft Bill
Gates got MSNBC the MS is Microsoft NBC
right Amazon got the Washington Post
it's like once you get enough money
where people should kill you because you
have that much money you need a
newspaper or something to be like yo
don't kill that guy
you know what I'm saying like that's
what all the articles are it's like you
know Amazon gives 100 million dollars to
this and it's just like yo don't kill me
is there not the difference between
something that's editorial and something
that's just a platform though like Bezos
can influence what goes out on the
Washington Post a lot more easily than
Elon can tell people what to tweet yeah
but Elon can also tweet whatever the
[ __ ] he wants and he can also never get
removed not only can it never get
removed but he can also remove [ __ ]
that's said about him that's fake
right he could be like that's fake news
he can't do that from The Washington
Post
they did that fact check thing didn't
they about uh
I'm not saying he would do this but he
can there's power yes you know you and
all news is on Twitter right now that's
what Twitter is it's really a news feed
right so the watching the post nobody
goes to the Washington Post to read an
article they see the article pop up on
Twitter and then they go to it so if
they're posting fake news about Elon he
could say yeah that's fake news adios
see you later they did that thing about
was it pensioners uh benefit checks and
it got fact checked by saying that the
reason that pensioners in the US are now
getting so much more money is because of
inflation and everything is adjusted for
inflation so the increase was massive
but the increase was based on the fact
that inflation is massive hilarious and
it was a whatever it's called a little
window below so they fact checked it
yeah and put it on the tweet and it was
like uh this is why this and it was
within like two days of Elon buying
Twitter it was [ __ ] hilarious I love
that did you see the new [ __ ] that just
came out today that the FBI the ex
Council to the FBI who was working for
Twitter got hold of the Twitter files
before they went to mataibi and uh the
other lady that was part of the Twitter
release and he it seems allegedly has
scrubbed the links between the FBI and
the hunt Biden laptop thing and he's now
been fired by Elon
you never stop working for the FBI
you think
once you're in you're in yeah I mean
you're more effective being a retired
FBI guy I don't trust retired CIA I
don't trust retired FBI you think
they're gonna let you retire with all
that information
you know what I mean it's like no this
is that's a lifetime job man if they
give you information they could shut the
whole thing down you're in for life and
you better know you're in for life it's
not like you do your 20 years and you
write your tell-all book we don't got
that many tell-all books right we got
the confessions of an economic Hitman he
just said the [ __ ] that we all know he
didn't really say anything and also he's
a scumbag for that don't like do it
profit off of doing it and then write a
book about how bad it is and then profit
off of that that's the liver King Arc
that's what's coming next which is what
that you go through the
villain and then I am now the hero that
is coming clean for what I'm not being
honest that's who I am yeah yeah and
then one of my friends is adamant that
his end goal is to become a WWE star
like that Alex asked him and he was like
we were like do you do wrestling he's
like oh I'm 45 and then he goes no no
like WWE so he actually thought that he
might like like be a wrestler yeah like
do some MMA [ __ ] yeah he was like nah
but uh I don't know if he's gonna do the
WWE maybe but yeah go do it and if that
was the whole goal then that would be
very deceptive yes I don't think that is
I think that I think that he he
genuinely
yeah I think he genuinely found
something that was very helpful to like
him and his family and he shared it and
monetized it and anytime you monetize
anything I'm going to be skeptical like
anytime there's money Associated I told
him I was like bro if you were an
accountant and you did this [ __ ] nobody
would question it no one would care
because you're not making any money off
it the second you make money off
something there's always a little bit of
a the incentives aren't going to be
quite as pure right yeah yeah man I mean
this is why huberman is such a [ __ ]
interesting example he's like what do
you suggest that I take for my fidojia
regressus or whatever [ __ ] supplement
it is and he just goes well I'm not
involved with any of these companies but
this is what I think and it gives you so
much Faith to what he's saying yeah is
genuinely what he believes yeah because
he has no incentive to say otherwise
like all that that guy sells I think is
maybe like ad-free access and t-shirts I
think he's gonna do some supplements or
he already eventually supplements
eventually he should do we should look
that up he might even have some now well
uh but he should because we trust him
right correct yeah but that's what
latent Leverage is right so
um imagine that you continue to give and
give and give and give to oh then it's
time to yeah to your audience and then
when they do they don't feel aggrieved
about buying [ __ ] from you 100 I think
that probably worked for me with the
special like I had given away so many
[ __ ] hours of stand-up comedy that
when I was finally like yo I really
believe in this thing this thing cost me
a lot of money
can you guys support me I think there
was a lot of people just DM me they're
like yo we'd be more than happy to thank
you like and that was really cool
because when you start giving away [ __ ]
for free so much you expect it to be
free in your head even though it's not
free for you to work out you know like I
put 15 years into this you know so I was
like but yeah that was a cool response
latent leverage latent leverage yeah you
just accumulate well I mean it's
garyvee's like job job right hook
philosophy if he was also like dating
it's like dinner dinner there it is
speaking of dating monkey pox
that's equal equal opportunities we've
got a lot more to talk about with Andrew
but first I need to tell you about whoop
it is the best fitness tracker that I
have ever found it's the only one that
I've ever stuck with and it tracks
absolutely everything from my sleep to
my recovery even the workouts that I do
every single day through this strap
which is on 24 7. my resting heart rate
my heart rate variability and even how
much I'm breathing throughout the night
tells me my quality of sleep it gives me
trends and reports over time but the
most important thing is it actually
nudges my behavior through suggest in an
app it's a digital coach not just a
fitness tracker and it encourages me to
change my behavior that will improve my
health over the long term even better
than that you can join for free pay
nothing for the brand new whoop 4.0
strap and get your first month for free
so you buy it for free try it for free
and if you do not like it after 29 days
they'll give you your money back head to
join.woop.com Modern wisdom to sign up
right now that's
join.woop.com
modern wisdom the manosphere give me
your thoughts on the manosphere yeah
what about the manosphere has always
existed it just got less funny
that's my issue with it it's like be
funny be funny about whatever it is like
like my my favorite Community the
greatest community of all time uh hands
down is Patrice O'Neill like Patrice
O'Neill's early manosphere like I don't
know if you watch any of his stuff like
I'm early manosphere like my stuff I've
got jokes that are like perfectly
aligned with manosphere [ __ ] but they're
jokes it's funny what was so great about
Tate was he was funny like Mark was
telling us there's one thing I didn't
even see this one he's like I'll never
let a girl drive my car
he goes uh they're like why he goes have
you ever thrown something at your girl
and she caught it
[Laughter]
like you could take he's got lines you
could take and go on stage and that's
why I was so effective it's like it it
tapped into almost like borsche belt
comedy remember have you heard like
what's that like old back in the day
comment like the take my wife please
these one-liners right these one-liners
were all incredibly offensive but they
tap into feelings that we have and our
feelings are not the things we execute
you get cut off you want to be like I
want to [ __ ] kill that person but you
don't really kill them it's a momentary
feeling so you have frustration with
your wife that take my wife please
everybody in the audience every husband
who's dealt with their wife bitching
about something you know in there oh I
relate to that moment I relate to that
feeling because Tommy's about feelings
not about truth it's not about what
should be true it's about a feeling that
is real that you've had so
I think what happens with these jokes is
they tap into moments of what it is like
to be a guy in this day and age and then
not funny people got into it and ruined
it like everything and then started
taking every single line seriously and
then when you start to take every single
lines seriously you just seem like
you're hate women you're angry at women
you're bitter that's not I don't think
anybody really at the end of the day
wants to resonate with that the
fundamental way that it's positioned is
that men and women are enemies or
adversaries they're trying to extract
something from you yeah it's kind of
dangerous to think about like that
I don't know it doesn't seem like a
particularly healthy way to create a
foundation to build stuff up from that
and the problem is I also understand
right like I was a guy in my 20s who
didn't understand the world and himself
and [ __ ] everything so you go to the
Internet it was just fortunate for me
that I landed on like Jordan Peterson
and Sam Harris and whatever as opposed
to some other channel because you're
looking for answers and this person
comes across here's another Dynamic that
I always notice certainty with the way
that people speak yeah
maybe this is just like inbuilt [ __ ]
unconfidence in knowing things yeah but
for me I've always got like caveats and
a little bit of just I'm not so sure but
I feel like this is the right way yeah
when people come out of somewhere and
say this is the way that things are
here's a meme or a cool word or like a a
brand that makes it seem like a [ __ ]
legitimate academic topic this is a
thing and this is the way that it is it
seduces people it's one of the reasons
that so many political commentators
online like Ben Shapiro is a perfect
example of this you know whether you
agree with the guy or not he's [ __ ]
certain about all of it yeah and you go
well wow like that sounds compelling he
gives you the weapons for your feelings
that's why I look at badass right it's
like you're conservative you don't know
why and then he's going to give you the
best arguments as to why right you think
abortion should be banned Ben's going to
tell you why I should be banned and he
will do it amazingly succinct perfect
data he just gives you the weapons for
when you get into an argument at a bar
that's very interesting I think there's
a lot of people who tend to do that but
for me they're not the most interesting
the funny people are interested to me
regardless of what they feel and I
separate that like my loyalty is to
funny so like a guy like Dr Umar Johnson
which might have like many beliefs that
I disagree with is also the funniest
communicator on the internet so no
matter what he says I'm watching it it
is gonna be hilarious I'm just thinking
of things I can't even say out loud
because they're so crazy but when he
does
they're [ __ ] hilarious so that's the
power of Comedy it's like you really
want to communicate some [ __ ] whether
you believe it or not comedy is the
vessel and when these people don't have
any comedy and they're being like really
serious and trying to execute these
points and we gotta [ __ ] save the
world it's like shut the [ __ ] up so I'm
not sure that you always need comedy for
instance heedman is a good example yeah
doesn't use comedy an awful lot
communicates points they make it great
they make a great impact but I do think
that you need to have a level of
humility
um like collaboration as well as opposed
to this very adversarial sort of
zero-sum type scenario another one of
the influences here as well I went to
Miami for the first time ever
um two and a half three weeks ago yeah
and um
a lot of what I was seeing online in
men's advice made a lot more sense after
I'd been to Miami
unlocked the back of my brain yeah in
terms of going
oh like what were you saying so for
instance uh your wealth is your primary
uh source of value to the world who you
are the person that you're with the
table that you're on the size of the
bottle the girls that are on your arm
what it is that the girls how they were
dressed like girls out in party dresses
Maxi party dresses at 12 midday going
for coffee in heels like where the [ __ ]
are you going yeah what is this and
that to me made a lot of sense because
it seems like a good chunk of Miami
culture very transactional very
transient very resource-based has
informed a lot of men's advice on the
internet and because of that their
reverse engineering Miami is how all
women are right right no it's [ __ ]
not I've met half a million women in my
life stood on the front door of
nightclubs yeah no it's [ __ ] not yeah
most women on average are caring and
kind and want a [ __ ] guy that they
can get into a relationship with that
cares about them yeah some of them [ __ ]
up and some of them are outright mean
and nasty and all the rest of it but so
are guys yeah like I just my personal
experience which is [ __ ] vast does
not suggest that girls are like the
ruthless gold diggers that everybody
says however I agree think about you're
a guy in the insane you're a guy on the
internet who doesn't have much
experience with women
so what you do is you start consuming
content from people who seem like they
do and maybe they're consuming content
that feeds your fears precisely but what
are the sort of stories that are
sufficiently newsworthy to break through
onto the internet they're the most
egregious transgressions of this
particular it's the the girl that got
into a relationship with some Canadian
guy and took all of his money and now he
lives on the street and you can't ever
see his kids and his dog hates him and
while he was sleeping went out [ __ ] a
guy in a gas station came back that's a
real story like yeah all of that yeah
those are the stories that break through
so if you don't have real world
experience that can disprove that yeah
quite rightly you're vehemently going to
think these [ __ ] are out here trying
to [ __ ] get us I need to be horribly
uncertain whenever I'm around a woman
like I don't blame the guys for thinking
it to be honest with you I think that
like there's a lot of frustration when
you're not in control your sexual
Destiny and there's two ways to handle
that frustration there's there's one is
go inward the others go outward right
I'm frustrated it's like well what can I
do to alleviate that frustration can I
like get better at chat can I learn what
these girls are interested in and like
how to make them feel comfortable right
or do I justify that frustration by
going outward which is all women are
gold diggers they don't like me because
I'm [ __ ] short or they don't like me
because I'm skinny or they don't like me
because I'm poor or yada yada so yeah I
think a lot of times my issue with the
manosphere is it it's presented as if
the frustration is is is is handled
inward but make yourself a high value
man whatever that which you do not need
to be to get laid I think the guys that
got laid the most when I was younger
were not high value they were just good
at chat is that no value it is value but
not in
the
gold digging sense like if we're if
we're looking at all women as gold
diggers
and they're these guys that are broke
but they can talk them up now they must
not be gold diggers right now these
girls on some level just want to be made
to feel comfortable want to be listened
to want to be entertained want to laugh
right but it's much easier I think to go
all they care about is money when you're
not that good at talking
when you're not that Charming when
you're not that interesting and when
you're not that interested like I think
the best advice I ever got about women
was just uh just get them to the point
where you can listen
what's that mean
once someone feels comfortable talking
to you especially a woman like that's a
level of comfort and confidence that is
going to separate you from every other
person at that bar like once they're
sharing their feelings they're talking
about their opinions Etc it's like
that's you you're in that's it it's
yours to lose at that point so it's like
I think a lot of times guys go in it's
like I have to demonstrate value I have
to show you how cool I am oh look at my
car I'm gonna drop my keys on the table
there's a [ __ ] Lamborghini thing I
hope she sees that no
simple as that ah work sucked man yeah
what do you do oh yeah you do okay yeah
is that difficult
oh it is kind of difficult yeah it does
kind of seem kind of annoying to do
nothing yeah it is kind of noise
just talking away to the races well
you're a guy who's completed that now
you know as a rehabilitated ex-party boy
who's now being married is the best why
no it's horrible I'm gonna be awesome
no that's great it is the best but the
thing is that we don't share it's the
best because that's not fun I was
talking about this with the guys on
flagrant but it's like you don't share
good parts of your [ __ ] relationships
with your boys there's nothing fun about
that you know climb calling my boys up
today and be like oh man I had I had a a
great chat at brunch with my wife and we
really understood each other and felt
safe and loved and vulnerable like my
friends don't want to hear that [ __ ]
[ __ ] right they want to hear the
annoying thing that my wife did to me
that made me look like a [ __ ] idiot
then we all laugh at me or we laugh at
my wife whatever it is that's just way
more entertaining so there's things we
share but just to not be involved I
think in the rat race is great at my age
I'm 39. that's another thing I had a
great time partying I'm glad I got it
all out of my system I don't have the
fomo that a lot of guys do a lot of guys
get hitch young and then they have to
deal with their whole life what would it
be like correct
have threesome or something like that
what would it be like to go to Miami and
see if you've got to take the boxes off
man exactly and I'm glad I did that
there's at this point there's nothing
that I'm like I wish that I did that
before I got married so I just get to
focus on developing this relationship
one of my boys was big into pickup
Artistry about 10 years ago and I
remember him speaking to me and he was
saying it's like dude you're really
[ __ ] like committed to this pickup
[ __ ] like you really really are like
where's it coming from yeah he says yeah
my future wife better be thankful for
this I'm like
you're gonna have to explain why your
future wife should be thankful that
you're running through half of this city
at the age of 23. and he said I don't
want to walk down the street with my
wife and my two kids and my dog and look
at a Brazilian chick and think I wonder
what it's like to [ __ ] a Brazilian chick
yeah I want to have closed every
different Loop every different desire
all the different quirks even the monkey
pox I want to have got it all yeah yeah
and that was what he wanted and I do
think that there's another did he live
up to it I have no idea maybe
monkeypoxed or not Jordan if you're
listening tell me if you're monkey pox
[ __ ] he he definitely put the time in
man I'm not sure how his future wife
will feel about it but yeah there is a
part of that gotta close off 100 yes
yeah I think that that's I think that's
healthy as long as you're not justifying
it to yourself like that you know I
think my one issue with the pickup
artist stuff because my dad literally
sent me that book I remember being in
college when it came out the game yeah
he sent me the book he goes hey there's
this was written in the New York Times
and I don't know what that says about
like how my dad thought I was with women
but he was like you should read this uh
you're [ __ ] hopeless you might need
the only way I'm going to get some
grandchildren is if you read this
[ __ ] bookie here I am 17 years later
no uh but but yeah he said and I thought
it was fascinating I thought it was like
really cool that guys even tried to like
scientifically break down what it was it
created that kind of chemistry my one
issue with it always was like
using the same lines I thought was corny
and the fight outside between two
midgets exactly yeah like or whatever
the the [ __ ] there's a bunch of them
and I was just like Ugh like how
embarrassing would that be if you use a
line then somebody else at the bar also
use it on the girl you're like oh just
just awful right the and then the other
thing I didn't like I didn't like
dropping a girl's confidence
so that she would like me because it is
so nagging yeah I like teasing I think
teasing is good I don't think it's good
to do so you can drop their confidence
so that you you will be above them like
my feeling is like if you hang out with
me long enough I think I'm the [ __ ] so
if you hang out with me long enough
doesn't matter where you think I am
initially
I'm coming up
so I don't have to hurt your feelings in
order to get my confidence doesn't need
to stand on the shoulders of yours
exactly I want you at your most
confidence
not eventually you're going to become
confident two things
either I have to keep you with a lack of
confidence in order for you to like me
or
that confidence is going to go back to
where it normally should it's going to
reach homeostasis for you and then
you're going to be like oh I don't like
this [ __ ] the [ __ ] am I with
this guy Phil exactly well that's
fundamentally one of the problems with
people who get into relationships where
their mate value isn't matched so I
spent all this year learning about this
evolutionary psychology stuff right so
there's terms of what you're talking
about yeah so benefit affordable I
studied in Santa Barbara benefit
affording you both help and you grow
cost inflicting you bring the other
person down so one of the ways that you
can ensure that your mate won't leave
you is to make them feel worse about
themselves yeah if you've got a
disparity in the make value one person
seems to be pulling away then the other
maybe they're getting more confident or
better looking or they've got more
attention or social status or whatever
it is one starts to pull away you can
either raise yourself up to match to
that benefit affording or you can drag
them back down so that they're closer to
you and a lot of the pickup artist stuff
was like that and another thing another
problem was that people are the girls
that you were using this on weren't
falling for you yeah they were falling
for the Persona yeah
and I think a lot of guys that did pick
up look at them now Neil Strauss took a
Max both good examples
both of them are like these [ __ ] like
awakened like psychedelic Warriors
tweeting about like enacting your
[ __ ] truest self forward and [ __ ]
Neil pulled the Confessions of a Hitman
I think he put out a book about the
importance of relationships yeah I think
so that's kind of crazy but it's because
I think that you realize after a while
of the sort of super transactions yeah
it's empty yeah you come back on the
other side and now Tucker's got this
Ranch in Austin and like four kids and
30 cheap and all this other [ __ ] yeah
like that's his thing yeah and maybe it
took them that to get there like
sometimes you need to to go through that
part of your life to realize you don't
need it it's vapid and empty yeah yeah
you got to close those loops and it's
fun it is fun dating is Fun
the Heartbreak isn't fun of course but
like meeting a new person like going
through those butterflies like is it
gonna go down is it not like these
things are exciting for sure
um but I don't think they're close not
even close to as fruitful as like
developing an actual relation
relationship with somebody and that is
when I'm when I say that like I mean
like a real relationship like you are
building something together not just
someone to watch Netflix with exactly
like like if you have a prenup you're
you don't have a relationship you have a
prenup no
you have a girlfriend
if you have a prenup you have a
girlfriend you're not building something
you have an escape hatch
you have a girlfriend that you created a
loop that you could get out of to call
her your wife for her but it's your
girlfriend because you could break up
whenever you want and everything's okay
a real relationship the way that like
marriage was designed is we are in this
[ __ ] and we got to fight through this
and we got to work on this and develop
this [ __ ] love and I think you do
that without the uh what is it called
the parachute now I've been married a
year I could come back from five years
like I was a [ __ ] idiot Chris what
the hell was I talking about you know I
why would I do that you know what I mean
I'm broke who knows but for me I like
that more I think it's cooler
yeah I think that that's more exciting
talking about heartbreak not often the
Andrew Tate and Jordan Peterson agree
but both of them I've seen have got the
same take where they think that
heartbreak is worse for guys than it is
for girls and Tate had this really
[ __ ] interesting video where he
explained that because of the inbuilt
possessiveness that men have
the thought of their ex-partner now
being with a new partner is so painful
that to them it's going to be more
painful than it would be for a woman who
might be emotionally uh distressed by it
and the other part of it was that women
uh a heartbroken woman is someone that
deserves sympathy and respect a
heartbroken guy is like [ __ ] come on
man man up now I'm not sure how much I
agree with both of those but it's a
[ __ ] interesting take yeah it's a
very interesting take to think about the
possessiveness that guys have over even
their exes even X's that they don't want
anymore I don't know whether you've ever
had this where you've had an
ex-girlfriend that you've let go by to
buy and then there's still something
about them like you see they've moved on
and you've moved on you've already moved
on and yet there's still a little like
twinge like I didn't exit I broke up
with I broke up with and then we were
still like friends and then she had told
me she slept with someone else and I was
like disgusted
I was like and I knew I was wrong to be
disgusted I was like why the [ __ ] like
shouldn't there be more time all these
kind of things 100 but for me heartbreak
was never about them being with someone
else
yeah the the the the Heartbreak was
always just like the sadness of not
having that person that you are loving
and is loving you I I never would jump
to oh she's gonna be with someone else
now so that's to me that's new
information I'm not even thinking about
the next person because I'm thinking
about this moment right now where yeah I
don't know I think that that's weird
that's like that means the only reason
you loved your wife is because she's not
[ __ ] other guys that's a weird reason
to love that person I'm not sure that'll
be the reason that you love them but it
might be the reason why heartbreak hurts
so much on the other side of it I don't
think it's a reason that you stay
together but I mean it would hurt if
she's sleeping with someone else 100 but
I wouldn't go there until they did and I
wouldn't be heartbroken off of the
hypothetical I would be sad because now
this person I really love is no longer
in my life that's me personally I don't
know how do you think about it
have you been heartbroken before yeah
yeah and what was it was it was a
heartbreak about that person being with
other guys no no it wasn't but there was
there was some juvenile possessiveness
that came through
um like after the fact like
ex-girlfriends and even girls that I was
just seeing for a while and be like why
the [ __ ] is this sort of
this fear and resentment and bitterness
around them moving on when I didn't want
to be with them no more yeah but you
don't want them to stop wanting you yes
yes but that's super juvenile that's
very very immature I don't even know if
his
yeah I think it's just insecure I don't
even know if it's juvenile I just think
it's insecurity and that's our
insecurities like we still want to be
loved and if you [ __ ] this other guy
what you you stop loving me that's crazy
like I still want that love so I could
move on with ease
the greatest gift you can give a woman
in a breakup is hating you
because it's easier for her yes but we
all try to do this soft Landing [ __ ]
we're like oh let's be friends whatever
because we're selfish right it's like I
don't want to be the one inducing this
pain in you so we'll do this very easy
calm break that's way more painful for
them because they're not really broken
up haven't got a reason to hate you and
we're still getting all the love that we
want because we don't want that love to
stop immediately so yeah but the
greatest gift you can give hatred I
heard that um people who are scared of
breaking up with the partner because
they're worried about how it's going to
make them feel mostly guys to girls uh
that that's not a sign of empathy it's a
sign of narcissism 100 you think that
you are so important that this girl who
lived her entire life up until the
moment that she met you she won't be
able to get older can no longer exist
after you decide to drop the bomb I
thought One X was gonna kill herself how
arrogant is that I'm like how could she
live without me you know what I mean I
called her mom I was like you better
check on her like I'm not in her life
you know I'm saying that's ludicrous
isn't that meanwhile she's fine exactly
but
sad but fine yeah yeah speaking of Tate
yeah Tate versus Jake Paul yeah what do
you think happens
are they actually gonna fight they had a
Face-Off I think if they don't it is
even for somebody that has as many
resources as both of those guys do
they're dropping the bag big time if
they don't do it surely I mean there's
got to be name me a bigger fight that
could happen that would draw more Normal
public attention Than Jake Paul fighting
Andrew Tate
bigger fight uh Jake Paul vs Canelo
Alvarez that would be bigger I think in
order for the fight to be Big Jake needs
to be the heel
that's a [ __ ] interesting question
yeah that's the interesting question
yeah what sort of [ __ ] world have we
got ourselves into where Jake Paul's the
hero in a [ __ ] face down like only
only if you find like a guy from the the
depths of like the [ __ ] Ninth Circle
yeah and drag him out and here's Andrew
Tate as the [ __ ] bad guy yeah
it's crazy like are we supporting
[ __ ] Jake Paul and I don't know if he
will I mean I'm just I just know from me
like I think actually this could be an
absolutely amazing fight and Jake might
have gotten too good for this to be a
successful but Jake Paul vs Nate Diaz to
me was always the ultimate one and I
think Jake has actually gotten
too much respect for that to be as
interesting like I think most people go
into that fight going oh I think Jake
will beat up Nate Diaz really before
there was like there's no chance but we
also said that about Anderson Silva we
said that about Tyrone what we said
about all these people we're gonna have
to accept that Jake is a really [ __ ]
good boxer so but I think the best fight
is Jake against a qualified MMA guy that
people love and Jake is the heel and
he's doing what he does best which is
troll antagonize I mean did we not did
we not see McGregor versus uh Mayweather
as an absolute super fight that's two
heels
yeah and it was really interesting that
like Mayweather almost became a face and
he didn't know what to do yeah
would you not love to see what happens
when like an immovable object meets an
Unstoppable Force at the press
conference I'm very Pro take take Paul
like massively you can make money off of
it I want them to make money I just
don't know why Tate would do it but
again I don't have an idea of his
finances like if if you told me Jake if
you told me tate is worth 200 million
dollars I would say no there's no reason
to do this at all like to risk permanent
damage he's he's already said he has
like some cornea issues or eye issues
like this isn't going to be [ __ ] good
for you I think he's maybe 34 35
something like that yeah it's it's not
if you have a hundred million you
couldn't get me to do [ __ ] with 100
million 100 million bro just in bed
I'm not fighting
for a hundred million no like I don't
know why you would do that because now
what are you doing it for you're doing
it to prove
something to the public I guess you you
know went back and forth with him but
Jake is a legit [ __ ] boxer man like
this guy's dedicated his life to it and
he was young younger when he got into it
he's not one of these like 40 year old
guys that does the celebrity boxing the
kid was in his early 20s and then
dedicated every [ __ ] second to every
day to it you know so
yeah I don't know if I'm Tate if I would
do that I wouldn't do that if I'm taped
because you got the money why risk it
and then I suppose one of the risks for
this is every single time that Jake Paul
steps into the ring with somebody he can
only win if he gets beaten he goes look
it was [ __ ] Anderson Silva Tyron
Woodley it was whoever they are
disillustrious it's Canelo Alvarez it's
j it's [ __ ] Andrew take right you
know full-time kickboxing world champion
every single person that steps in must
have like ass splitting nerves about if
this guy [ __ ] knocks me out I'm an
embarrassment correct how can you be the
top G it's not very tab G to lose to
Jake Paul
maybe it doesn't happen you've made me
think that it doesn't happen I would
never do it if I'm Andrew tape because
the reality is Jake Paul is probably
going to beat you and that's not saying
that you're not an incredible fighter
clearly he's a [ __ ] kickboxing world
champion like one of the best kickboxers
of his time there's no doubt right we
know that for a fact
you probably haven't kickboxed him years
if you've done any training at all you
know that the instincts not just the
muscles atrophy the instincts do the
timing does like you take a year off the
time he's not there
this guy Jake has been in the [ __ ]
ring now granted he's big I mean how
tall is Andrew six two probably Oh I
thought he was taller okay they're about
the same they're about the same height
yeah I wouldn't do it if I'm Andrew
especially if you got 100 Mil in the
bank that's there's no way yeah
Legacy counts for a lot man but then
press some 14 year olds on the internet
yeah I was Adam and he was gonna all
right so who does Jake fight next do you
think Nate Diaz Nate Diaz that's the one
that you would make
if you were the [ __ ] King maker Nate
Diaz because you want to Rattle up the
MMA crowd you want everybody in MMA MMA
is bigger than boxing right now so it's
like you want everybody in MMA to be
rooting for the MMA guy because you have
to tap into like a stream that's bigger
than you if you really want to make
things big it can't be just your
following my following we have to
discuss an issue that all these other
people also feel and ideally they don't
even know the [ __ ] we are but they tap
it into our comments we want tribalism
you want in-group out group you want
them and us
bare minimum tribal curiosity yep so
like when we put out I imagine you're
gonna put out clips from this podcast
every one of those clips is going to tap
into an issue not you not me maybe a
couple clips of a Schultz about this but
it would be about a topic that's bigger
than the both of us and ideally people
who don't even know the [ __ ] we are find
us they find you they go I like the way
this guy talks in interviews maybe I'll
listen to his other stuff yeah but we're
tapping into something bigger right like
so what's the umbrella that's what I'm
looking at when I look at a fight with
them I'm like okay what's the umbrella
the MMA crowd is desperately trying to
prove that they're as qualified Strikers
as boxers the boxers are desperately
trying to prove that boxing is a much
better martial arts is a much better
form of defense and you have those two
groups using Jake and whoever he's
fighting as proxies yes do you know what
I mean it's like the war in Ukraine
right it's like Afghanistan you don't
really want the fight the fight ain't
about the Taliban versus whatever it's
about United States versus Russia
that's what I want the boxing match to
be so that and I want you know the
whoever's boxing to make the most
[ __ ] money possible it's a horrible
way to make a living so I hope Jake
makes [ __ ] tens of millions of
dollars and then retires
soon he was talking about he's already
getting some was it speech slurring or
maybe something was up with his thoughts
that's what he was saying bro can you I
mean what time how old is he now like 26
20 not even dude okay so let's say let's
say that Jake Paul's 26 25 26 and he's
been doing this full-time five years
four years something like that that's
quick and in the space of that long is
seeing Nero degeneration he's speech is
changing something up with his eyes
[ __ ] wild yeah yep and that's what
I'm saying the kid is committed he's
because you're putting not only your
health but literally your lifespan on
the line as well like Jake is 100 lost
maybe months maybe years from the amount
of time he's going to be alive because
he wants to pursue this purpose sport at
the moment yeah [ __ ] insane that's
who you're dealing with so think about
someone that's prepared to kill
themselves sooner yeah you're dealing
with that level of commitment are you
that committed you got 100 million in
the bank you got private jets you're the
top G you got all these girls you got
Bugattis you got everything you're
dealing with the kid who's willing to
give it all away you have it all he's
trying to get to top G if he hasn't I
don't know how much money is I'm
assuming he has that much money I'm
never taking that you got to be crazy
I mean I give him a lot of respect for
doing it because if he honors martial
arts that much or something whatever
[ __ ] [ __ ] but no [ __ ] way uh
no five point that kid's hungry
all right guys we'll get back to that in
one second but first I need to tell you
about athletic greens you are not eating
in a fruit and vegetables in your diet
and you know it and this is going to
help Dr Andrew human and Tim Ferriss
have been harping on about it for years
and I always wondered why it is the best
green strength that I've found and I've
tried pretty much everyone it tastes
great and it gives you nutritional
insurance through 75 vitamins minerals
and Whole Foods sourced ingredients in
one scoop that you take every single day
if you're starting the new year looking
to give yourself some good nutritional
improvements this is a great place to
begin and there is a 60-day money-back
guarantee so you can buy it and try it
for 59 days and if you do not like it
they will give you your money back also
you get a Year's free Supply vitamin D
five free travel packs free pots shakers
and that 60 day money back guarantee
head to athleticgreens.com wisdom that's
athleticgreens.com wisdom
do you know why people don't [ __ ] their
sisters
yeah
yeah
why
um
that's too much fun
you know it's like an ugly ugly sisters
it fits perfect you know it's like it's
Lego
you know what I mean so I learned about
this I gotta [ __ ] I gotta tell you I
don't know I gotta tell you about the
[ __ ] so I learned this [ __ ] I gotta tell
you about it right so there's something
called the Western Mark effect okay what
it seems like happens
um let's say that me and you are brother
and sister yeah I can't tell that you're
my genetic relative right there's no
um like [ __ ] little code on your face
you would be able to notice an affinity
but you wouldn't necessarily you're not
disgusted sexually disgusted because of
that the reason is because of this thing
called the Western Mark effect okay so
what happens is infants that are raised
together for a good amount of time
throughout their infancy usually between
the age of like one to two until uh like
puberty age yeah what they do is they
look at their parents and the family
around them and they see who is mum
giving attention to who am I being
raised with who's she breastfeeding if
you're the older sibling you look at um
did that baby like come out of mum and
around the time of labor was she holding
this baby that then became my brother or
sister and that's called the Western
Mark window right so you have this
period of time and what you get is this
sexual disgust imprinting so that's why
you don't have sex not because of some
inbuilt [ __ ] innate I know that
you're my brother or sister it's because
of this window now the interesting thing
happens when brother and sister are
split apart at Birth they'll [ __ ] not
necessarily but well I mean in the same
like amount of hit rate that two random
people on the street would do but they
don't have sexual disgust because they
haven't lived together for that time
yeah same thing goes for the father that
leaves the daughter's life and then
comes back in later in life and you
think maybe already daddy issues but
also there's something about this person
it seems like humans have a
predisposition they have an affinity
toward people that resemble them a
little bit you actually see you'll see
them if you look at couples walking down
the street like you kind of look alike a
little bit and there is an affinity for
that so what you end up with is this
very dangerous situation where two a
brother and sister have been taken apart
can then come back together and they
don't have that sexual disgust in
Indonesia there was a period where
families would adopt the daughter of
another family when she was a newborn
and betrothed her to their son raised
them together but what they didn't
realize was that they were putting them
through this Western marker window and
it meant that even though they weren't
genetically related they had sexual
disgusted yeah how interesting so [ __ ]
so what would happen would they have sex
with one another with difficulty I mean
like brother and brothers and sisters
have done it before but it's [ __ ]
hard like it's very very ingrained yeah
to do that you should give them some
credit like for getting past it yeah
like a lot of Viagra and a [ __ ] good
point we tease all these like
Southerners they're like oh it's all
incest blah blah he's like brother
[ __ ] whatever like that but like I
guess what you're trying to say is like
we should honor them for for their
ability to break through the Westmark
barrier right is that what your point is
that's not can you bring this up to
justify incest I don't justify it like
more incest give them a medal
you're like like you couldn't [ __ ] your
sister you [ __ ] you know what I mean
let me [ __ ] but that guy did well I know
that you don't have a sister yeah and
I'm an only child so that you know of
you could have smashed out your sister
in leads or something like that he could
have been up in leads oh [ __ ] separated
at Birth she had curly hair and a big
jawline [ __ ] stupid accent dude
imagine adopted people got to worry
about all the time do you not remember
um that sperm donor guy there was that
documentary on Netflix that dude that it
turned out he was the fertility doctor
and he was using his own sperm this is
in Brazil no he's in the U.S oh really
it's on Netflix now it's [ __ ]
brilliant and
um this guy he like oh that's right yeah
like [ __ ] everybody and they were all
thinking that apparently one of the
women said exactly that which is like
waiting for the list of names to come
through and praying that it wasn't an
ex-boyfriend
but remember about that like she can we
also point this out like a lot of them
wouldn't have gotten like doctor
genetics
now I'm not saying they should be
grateful right but you know but like
they're probably objectively smarter
because of utility doctor yeah like I
mean is that not MD I don't know I don't
know maybe they've got the Psychopaths
fast it's bad what he did yeah but all
those kids are smarter imagine they're
dumb dads dude I mean fixing Plumbing
all day and [ __ ] like that coming home
to this smart ass [ __ ] kid right
don't gym shark don't cancel me yeah but
like think about it like they're smarter
because of it they were able to figure
it out because of that [ __ ] doctor
Gene one of those kids got to the bottom
of it because of the father because of
the gift that the father gave them yeah
so they done they did a study where they
got guys to imagine tongue kissing their
sister right you pulled the face so what
they were doing was they were videoing
the facial expressions of these guys I
was doing this because my sister would
also have a big nose so I was like just
getting out of the way it hits the mic
sometimes I've noticed yeah
um and uh they had they were tracking
the facial expressions and they can
um categorize them yeah they could say
this is disgust this is happiness it's
blah blah blah yeah yeah and they found
that right on cue some of the guys were
like oh and some of the dudes were so
far back that the camera went out with
Focus however the guys that didn't have
sisters showed a like a disproportionate
amount of like Smiles curling at the
edge of the mouth because it's like
there's no sexual there's no like
incestor version there's no sexual
disgust for that why do you think we're
so into like the stepsisters and that
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] fascinating
question I don't know why like incest
porn and stepmom porn that's popping
right now isn't it the incest Punch Yeah
and the stepmom porn well I think this
the military pandemic related like we're
all in the house together and it's like
the only person you're seeing is your
stepmom maybe there's definitely
something to do with the MILF thing
which is like an older more powerful
woman that can say what she wants I
think that's that's attractive I think
that's one of the reasons that guys go
toward the MILF thing I mean why do you
why why are people [ __ ] that's what
guys are turned on by that some guys are
some guys are turned on by like [ __ ]
[ __ ] pawn and all sorts of stuff yeah
what do you think about that that [ __ ]
thing is so odd I really can't oh yeah
we were talking about that I'm sorry I
really can't come up with a good example
or a good a good explanation for it I've
got a guy coming on next year who's one
of the Premier researchers into cooking
um so I'm going to ask him and I'll find
out like what it is he's the premiere
one of them there's not many imagine
being like the worst like yeah I'm one
of the worst researchers in cockporn
like listen I watched my wife get [ __ ]
a lot like I've been no idea why it's
happening yeah I just can't figure out
why I love it so much
that's a premier researcher has he tried
it is it like some kingsy [ __ ] where
like oh he's doing it for himself I have
no idea I don't know man but what we're
saying out there is the the you're
trying to control an uncontrollable
situation right like you're getting
cheated on a lot so you're like okay I'm
just gonna allow this as if you're in
charge but being in the room and
watching it as a way to like almost
desensitize yourself yeah I don't know
dude I have a friend who uh was trying
non-monogamy for the first time and his
wife was upstairs banging her boyfriend
while he was downstairs stays dry
wretching on all fours on the bathroom
like bathroom counter and his
driver distracting what is that oh
throwing up like had nothing to bring up
but just she was also up there like
like isn't that interesting that like
she was on all fours also dry wretching
[ __ ] in in unison together it's like
we're still together
um and he said he justified this is fun
mate
and uh yeah he was like oh it was at the
time he's now realized different at the
time he's like dude I think I was just
working through my trauma you know like
I was just letting go of the ego I was
allowing it to evaporate yeah I'm like
maybe maybe that's just something that
you shouldn't be doing maybe you just
maybe it's such an excuse for everything
that we do that's [ __ ] up because I
was working through my trauma
you know like no no you just something's
off right there my dude also we have too
many names for things we got to stop
naming weird [ __ ] because it normalizes
it but like like non-monogamy it's like
no no [ __ ] it just describe it
and then you're gonna feel embarrassed
and then you won't do it don't write a
name uncircumcised oh yeah I've told you
about that one yeah yeah yeah you saw
that on pbd I'm [ __ ] right I did what
the [ __ ] is going on I blew my blew my
mind yeah explain uncircumcised uh
yeah it's just a stupid word there's
just no point for the word yeah it's
just it's circumcising dick that's what
I was saying yeah we don't we don't call
things ungay you know what I mean but
this is the joke that I was trying to
make it was It was obviously with all
the Kanye stuff and you know the Jews
being controlled the media so in my mind
I'm like all right what's the funniest
way where I can make the argument that
Jews do control the media and then I
thought about uh the the dicks and I was
like yeah I'm circumcised well I have a
Jewish dick I'm not Jewish but my dick
is Jewish and uh that seems pretty good
control
I was in the car with a friend a couple
of weeks ago and his girlfriend was sat
next to me we were talking about this
exact thing yeah and she went uh honey
uh close your eyes for a second yeah I
have seen a lot of dick in my life I
have never seen one that's got a
foreskin I was like wow if you're in the
UK you would have struggled to see one
that didn't have a foreskin yeah in fact
if you're Brian you have too much like
you've got way more than you need
[ __ ] 90 foreskin yeah you could use
it as a burka like what he's doing over
there he's gonna do he's good when he
becomes my son he's gonna get
circumcised step into it like a sleeping
bag that's what that's for his new Pride
bro that's for his new Pride oh Brian
but yeah yeah it's a it's not it's a
fascinating term it's just yeah getting
he had such a weird thing why is it that
so many Americans are Jewish circumcised
um why what is Kanye's answer no uh no I
think I think it became like a health
thing at one point like people thought
it was healthier I've looked it up a
little bit but it is like it is an odd
tradition right and what's so
interesting about it is the way that
women perceive it like women
in America are
I don't want to say repulse but they're
not into the the whole thing intact yeah
yeah yeah and um
it is it's just it is a fascinating
thing that like you could create
perception and create a aversion to
something that is natural yeah like the
way it's supposed to look you know even
now yeah like I'm like mine looks better
yeah yeah well that was Bill MOS take
Bill what is it it just said that it's
it's so ugly I'm like well that's kind
of the same as saying like someone that
hasn't chopped an arm off is is more
more ugly but it's so [ __ ] you're so
right about it being like a cultural
conditioning thing yeah this is what
you're used to or what you think and
there's some sort of like predisposition
around it things does make them better
you're taking away so here's his thing
we do that all the time right we take
away fat you look better you know we we
add jawline we do these other things
I'll get into the [ __ ] meat and
potatoes of it uh you have a gossamer
thin amount of [ __ ] tissue yeah on
the [ __ ] Corona of the penis yeah
right yeah that's is protected by the
foreskin or the bell end as we call it
in the UK yeah like that [ __ ]
brilliant insult calling someone a bell
and it's so satisfying
um you get like keratinized balance over
time like the head of the penis becomes
like [ __ ] so you've got I can only
imagine that Jewish women have got to
like [ __ ]
oh oh loses sensitivity ABS 100 loses
sensitivity there is a huge movement
online that says male circumcision is
gentle mutilation for boys because it
down regulates the amount of pleasure
that they can get and isn't that good
because maybe our women come more
because of it because you can last
longer yeah interesting I'd love to see
someone do a study on this please we
gotta do a study really good how many
pumps can this how many pumps because
you guys are so sensitive you're busting
all early and we're out here just you
know smashing hips just smashing hips
dude we really might be that's a great
[ __ ] point shout out the Jews the
Jews knew that it's the most feminist
thing that they've done the Jews knew
the Jews knew that women need an orgasm
we need to desensitize these dicks they
just had them out there in the desert
just dragging along the [ __ ] sand and
[ __ ] and eventually it got to the point
where they're just making their women
come non-fucking stop this is brilliant
this is true it's like someone's chopped
the end off a baseball bat and it's
[ __ ] just dangling down there that's
it it's rock hard piece so yeah but
think about it if it's helping the women
out and help what is the most
embarrassing thing as a guy it's coming
tonight too soon yeah yeah I think they
should have chopped more of mine off
because I stay clean I think I only got
like a half can I take a bit more off
the top take it off my boy that is so
true short back insides please yeah so
is it super sensitive for you well I
don't know I've got nothing to compare
it to yeah it's like [ __ ] it's a dick
yeah so I think like yeah like when it
comes out is it like cold like oh
not usually temperature checked I'll
check next time but like when you clock
it back does it do you feel wind oh yeah
if it was Breezy absolutely oh really
yeah oh I don't feel what's yours like
the [ __ ] bottom of your foot exactly
cracked like [ __ ] yeah skin on the
back of your heel yes right yeah it's
Bert kreischer's heel that's not much do
you ever have to put one of those
compied things on that girls that wear
heels too much and get like [ __ ]
blisters like if it ever gets like
[ __ ] rubbing on the zip no but you
can't go oh actually we have underwear
in America yeah yeah but I was gonna say
if you go without the underwear and you
catch it on the back of a [ __ ] zip or
something you probably wouldn't even
notice you wouldn't even notice no no
it's still kind of sensitive but it's
not as sensitive as as you guys for sure
cool yeah let's go back we can compete
later on yeah yeah we'll see which is
more yeah we'll just flick it that'd be
good
I'm wondering is mine even that
sensitive that's an interesting one act
that's also another thing like if you
don't get hard
don't feel bad about it blame the Jews
oh because you desensitized me exactly
like this part of the Jewish conspiracy
to give me erectile dysfunction Kanye
Kanye talk to us you've missed one yeah
we call it whiskey dick it's not whiskey
dick it's yamaka yeah yeah yeah
that is good
that is good see how Comedy Works guys
this is fun
now if I wasn't a comedian it's just two
guys committing a hate crime on a
podcast
I've got the light I've got the light
above us thank you thank you very much
thank you
um [ __ ] here's another one so one of
my friends
his wife's sister is six foot two
without heels very tall wife sister wife
sisters
okay go on go on uh she was walking
through a supermarket and she was uh
lamenting the fact that she can't find a
partner that is taller than her like
women on average want to date someone at
least it's not shorter yeah right and uh
she's struggling and they're walking
around the supermarket and they see this
guy he's like six foot seven of The Far
Side probably really good looking dude
and she sees him on the edge of the
aisle she's like oh wow sort of nudges
the sister and says like am I gonna
speak to him and then they see him push
the trolley along as they follow him
around the eye like stalkers and they
see him go up to a five foot three girl
who pops something in the cart and like
gives him a kiss on the cheek and keeps
on going and she's like this short
[ __ ] [ __ ] she could have had five
five she could have had five six she
could have had five she could have had
five by four and it would have been fine
me meanwhile [ __ ] six foot two can't
find any Partners out there and she's
taking him up yeah is it the case that
girls that earn 30 grand a year
shouldn't be going for millionaires for
precisely the same reason this tall girl
problem they're capturing if you're a
[ __ ] PhD that earns half a
millionaire as a woman like you don't
date a broker dude precisely so should
it be the case that it's like you should
have a height limit so that it makes it
fairer for the dating world what do you
think that is kind of interesting women
are allowed to have standards
yeah
we're not really allowed to have that
how so it seems like there's more
scrutiny when we want standards but
women are allowed to have standards like
they they can date someone who they can
say I don't want to date someone who
makes less money than me and I do want
to date someone who is taller than me
and I want to date again all these
specific things and that's okay and when
we do that we're objectifying them in
some way I think that that's unfair
that's probably unfair but if they're
tapping into their biological impulses I
guess that's okay I guess the question
is when can we stop tapping into our
biological impulses well the equivalent
for men is that mandate younger
that is true so this is one thing that
the management that's what that has to
do with like uh fertility youth Etc
specifically right yeah well utilizing
fertility yeah but what is resources and
status for that's protection of your
baby that's why women tend to date up
and across yeah dominant dominance and
height in the men so like this is one of
the things that never really gets
discussed in the world of online men's
advice for dating yeah they'll always
point to women and say your hypergamy is
[ __ ] disgusting
um why is it that you want the
millionaire you don't realize that
you're a five out of ten and actually
you're trying to get like these guys
that is 0.1 of the entire population
yeah and you go okay has any guy ever
been told that they should date older
yeah because you're saying women your
inbuilt predisposition is wrong yeah
maybe there's that's Up For Debate but
if you're going to make that case you
have to say to men your preference for
younger women is also wrong yeah yeah
100 yeah I think that makes that and
it's not like we have a preference for
younger women always you just have a
preference for younger women as you get
older because that's where the fertility
um what would you say like it ranges
window yeah yeah window fertility unless
you're in Leonardo DiCaprio exactly well
he's not even trying to get him pregnant
just bouncing off the [ __ ] limit of
25 yeah yeah [ __ ] 25th birthday and
there's like a [ __ ] scheduled email
there's a scheduled email on a birthday
as soon as you get to the right time it
is like I mean she's excited if your
girlfriend number eight yeah and it's
your 25th birthday and you know that
it's happened seven times before you're
like I saw this coming yeah I don't know
I think if a woman
if a woman wants to have kids and she
doesn't prioritize a man's wealth in
some way when she's picking him she
doesn't care enough about her kids
because resources will give the kids a
better life not only better life like
security while she is unable to work
like bare minimum like if you have a job
that's going to give you [ __ ] nine
months of whatever it's called maternity
leave Etc okay then you can have a
little bit more security but I don't
think there's anything wrong with a
woman going okay I need some protection
what if I want to raise these kids what
if I want to give these kids the best
possible I don't think there's anything
wrong I wouldn't call it Golding it's
gold digging if you want a rich guy and
don't want kids then you're a gold
digging [ __ ] if you want 20 kids get a
rich [ __ ] that can afford them
that's beautiful the only thing that
makes you a gold digger is not wanting
kids
because once you have kids ideally your
focus should be on them it's not even
the things that you're gonna get the
your focus should leave you I don't have
kids yet but I want kids like my wife
and I are trying to have kids and I'm
excited for this part of my life where
it's not only about me or my wife
anymore it's about something else I'm
excited to live for something else
that's great
but yeah I don't think you're a golden
woman if you if you have kids at all the
problem that you have is most women want
to date someone that earns the same or
more than them I don't think anyone who
wants to date this the same they want to
date more right at the very least yeah
it would be except the same yes but they
would want more yeah the issue is that
women are out earning men two to one
women completing four-year U.S college
degrees women between 21 and 29 and 111
pounds more than men do so you have an
ever increasing group of women that are
high performing but that's date by the
way uh-huh not just [ __ ] [ __ ] is totally
different but you're going to have to
get past [ __ ] in order to get to date
for the most part that's if a dude wants
to here's the thing where I think
there's a there's like all these things
are true but I think the argument starts
to fall apart a bit of it because
the dudes that are incredibly frustrated
by women aren't trying to date and have
a girlfriend they're trying to get some
[ __ ] correct so and girls will give you
some [ __ ] even if you don't have a good
job and all this other stuff please
believe I got way I got plenty of [ __ ]
before I did anything right now I know
there's dudes right now that are and I
was joking around this on the podcast
but like if you ever want to be
complimented by a dude just tell them
you got [ __ ] before you were famous and
they're gonna tell you everything about
you why you got [ __ ] oh your handsome
your jaw you're in good shape all this
other [ __ ] not not your personality at
all that you they become the biggest
objectifier of you because they're
trying to they're trying to tell
themselves why they don't get [ __ ]
right so but 100 you can't girls are
willing to sleep with dudes that are
making that make them feel comfortable
safe and also laugh and enjoy and have a
good time obviously lifestyle helps
there's tons of dudes getting [ __ ]
because they got yachts and all this
other [ __ ] but uh you do not need that I
promise you do not need that at all to
get laid that is the biggest lie ever at
all
at all it's easier but you do not need
it I was living with my parents for
years bringing girls into their
apartment my mom drinking a [ __ ] 40
of Coors Light I mean it's crazy I don't
know why she would drink that Scottish
women shout this guy's one and then just
saying hello and like being an adult
late 20s
living with my parents crushing
they don't care so do you think there's
always talk on the internet about great
fun that's what they care about there
are so few guys that are fun
that is the rarest thing in the world a
guy who's genuinely fun well think about
one of the things that the current
dating advice would make people do make
them take their lives very seriously who
would make them take dating incredibly
seriously the interactions every
interaction you think is that this
person trying to take advantage of me do
I need to set the tone here do I need to
just have some [ __ ] fun laugh be
silly they will also be silly you'll
have a great [ __ ] time she might have
these requirements and eventually go you
know what this person isn't taking his
life uh I don't want to say seriously
but this person isn't at a place in
their life where I can move forward with
this but please believe you go to a city
like New York City where there's so many
women are just moving here they actually
are looking to hook up with God they're
like I want to hook up with my first guy
in New York oh I've never hooked up with
a Puerto Rican guy this is going to be
really fun they're going to be
objectifying you they got I've never
hooked up with a bartender from a thing
boom done I it is like the biggest myth
ever is that these girls do not want to
[ __ ] guys they do and they don't give a
[ __ ] what your value is what is your
value that night are you the funny guy
at the bar that night you're the highest
value made
simple as that I think you that you have
to almost lie to yourself a little bit
more
you have to you should lie to yourself
be like every girl in here is starved
for dick
and unfortunately I only have one but
that's the the mentality that you should
enter the room with I really do believe
that I think that would help you not to
mentality every woman in here is trying
to take my gold yeah
what a horrible way to live what do you
think about the body positivity movement
what about it so I saw a bill burbot
from uh his show at Red Rocks and he had
this really [ __ ] fascinating Insight
so I've learned about this thing called
intersexual competition right what
intra-sexual competition okay so women
competing with women for men and men
competing with men for women yeah the
current world both popular media and
also the men's online dating space yeah
is saying that
men and women are each other's
adversaries right their uh losses your
gain and vice versa but it seems like
most competition happens interest
sexually not intersexually and [ __ ]
burn nailed it in this piece what he was
saying was how have we got ourselves to
the stage where normal average can't
remember your [ __ ] name-looking women
have convinced all of their bigger
friends that they don't need to lose
weight
the reason for that is that it makes you
the hot one in your group of friends
you reduce your own intersexual
competition by encouraging body
positivity it's like [ __ ] keep on
eating you fat [ __ ] lose a toe like so
that I it made me see body positivity
through an entirely new [ __ ] lens
there's no woman that's proud to be fat
that is a myth
the this is not true the even the
skinniest women don't think they're
skinny enough like if you actually
believe that these fat girls on the
internet that are saying how proud they
are of their body are actually proud you
just don't know any women at all women
are constantly
scrutinized and for their weight it
doesn't matter how like even those fit
girl like the most fit athletic girl is
upset she's not skinny like a model and
that skinny girl that's a model is upset
she's not fit like the athletic girl
everybody is they're constantly worried
about their bodies like this idea that
there's these like fat confident chicks
no maybe if you've been fat your whole
life you've like learned how to accept
it and you have another confidence that
like these skinny girls don't have
because they're trying to live up to
these unrealistic expectations but I
truly do not believe every fat girl you
see walking down the street is like
proud to be fat while they're FIFA fo
fun and all over them all right like
there's they're Inc they're embarrassed
about that and they want to do something
to fix it right you don't want to come
on bro
okay listen do you want to do that you
walk into the Apple Store the iPads are
[ __ ] shaking and [ __ ] like that
that's not a that's a problem right that
is a problem you're trying to get a
brand new iPad the guy is telling you
about it it's popping out the charger
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on
here oh my God is there a beanstalk in
this right I think there's a beanstalk
in this Apple Store is that do you take
the Beanstalk to The Genius Bar like how
do I do you know I don't think there's
any girl that's actually confident about
that and I think they're trying to mask
that confidence we were talking about
you tell me about that that interesting
point now that thing I forgot about what
is that well I think that there's
there's a couple of things going on here
like you can and should be happy with
where you're at but also want more I
think the problem comes when you try and
tell other people that this is the way
that they should be right so that's the
inner Citadel the inner Citadel is I
damage my leg I try to fix it if I can't
then I chop it off and I announce that
the desire for legs is misguided and
must be subdued by everybody so how many
people that are a part of the body
positivity movement are there because
they struggle to lose weight and then
announced that the entire world's view
of weight and Health's link is
completely misguided and that's wrong
like you can be uh you know we're saying
here embrace the person that you are as
the the shorter guy that maybe doesn't
have as much money and maybe doesn't
have the right job but like what can you
do right so the same thing goes for this
you can be perfectly happy in the
position that you are without telling
everybody else that they need to adhere
to your biases yeah you have to accept
things you can't change I think the
thing with weight is we perceive it as
something that can be changed quite
easily especially if you have good
metabolism like if you're skinny without
doing nothing you're like oh you must be
fat because you're overeating and lazy
but the reality is is there are
different metabolisms right like some
people just are fatter it's harder for
them to lose weight they gotta try way
harder and they gotta sacrifice way more
now my question is like how much you
want to sacrifice we were talking about
this earlier like I would rather be fat
than David Goggins any day of the week
that seems like the worst life ever like
the guy got no [ __ ] toenails like
he's saying his knees are completely uh
devoid of any cartilage like it's a con
like he got a whole team just to get up
and run every single [ __ ] day and
it's like that sounds awful like I'd
rather be plump and enjoying meals with
my friends and like just embracing
dessert I love dessert I wonder why
they're awesome I wonder whether it's an
issue with theory of mind I wonder
whether it's because you can't imagine
what it would be like let's say I don't
think that this is necessarily the case
but let's say that Goggins takes as much
pleasure from running 30 miles a day yep
and doing 500 push-ups because you do
from going out with your friends let's
just say that that's the case let's say
that there is a person for whom they can
be as happy and confident at the size
that they are as the person that is in
whatever the shape is that's not to say
that there isn't on average I don't
think that that's the case for most
people I think that most people end up
being happy with the varied life that
gives them a good bit of freedom and has
a little bit of discipline yeah I agree
with you completely and again that was
just me personally based on what I value
right so uh the the one tricky thing
with with body positivity is the
assumption that these things are healthy
and I think nobody's saying don't love
your body what they're saying is don't
mislead people into thinking that that's
health
right like it is not healthy like
doctors say that this is not healthy and
I think that's the only pushback if
you're like yo I'm fat and I'm unhealthy
but I like to live like this I don't
think anybody's gonna be angry at you
why do I give a [ __ ] that you're fat but
what if they say I'm fat and I'm
confident like this great your life do
what the [ __ ] you want you're not
hurting me
I'm fat and this is healthy now you're
misleading people now there's other
people like okay I could potentially be
fat and you know I don't have to worry
about my body at all and you can I guess
do that but it is misleading it's not
it's not true there's a university in
Canada that recently took all of the
nutritional information off of the meal
plans that students had because then
seeing the calories on the back was too
triggering was too triggering too
triggering wow
wow why would that be triggering if
they're fine with how they look well I
don't think that they are I just think
that uh calories was seen as part of a
uh probably patriarchal superstructure
that is trying to keep people in their
place based on an arbitrary sense of
calories in calories out which is
Ambiance with you bro
I don't really believe in calories dude
don't believe in calories okay this is
interesting let's let's dig in
like I don't think liquid [ __ ] is
calories
I challenge you to drink a bunch of
Dunkin Donuts shakes and tell me
otherwise depends how liquidy it is but
like for example like I know this sounds
crazy but like
I yeah I just don't think I don't think
what if you drink a bunch of cream
is that not liquidy enough
let me tell you something bro
you shouldn't be drinking cream that's
absolutely disgusting but like ketchup
don't got no calories you know what I
mean like I guess liquid right yeah like
a Coca-Cola calories I get out of here
like if you just you know what I mean
like I just don't believe in it I don't
believe in it I don't think liquid [ __ ]
really got calories I think once you
make a liquid and calories go somewhere
else bro you should tell these students
in Canada Bread has calories I try to
stay off that bread that bread is
dangerous so by your logic this the most
solid the food is the more calories it
has like sofa cheese mad calories cheese
crazy calories cheese it depends is it
grilled
you know what I mean like if it's melted
if you get it while it's melted that's
no calories but if that [ __ ] starts to
coagulate a little bit just now some
caloric you know it is going up I'm just
tell like mayonnaise ain't got no
calories bro like there's certain things
when you liquefy I don't believe it you
can't tell me right now Fanta got colors
you can't tell me I drink a Fanta I'm
full human I never drink a Fanta and I'm
full Andrew I need to speak to you we
have we have someone that is not
Dr huben's on the phone you tell me
right now you tell me right now you
think how many calories is in a Fanta
180 or some [ __ ] like that probably like
200 200 calories yeah okay you drink a
Fanta and eat a Snickers which one makes
you more full
the Snickers because calories ain't real
because calories ain't real now I don't
think that they're not real in its
entirety but I think the system that
we're using is [ __ ] up bro I don't
think it's legit let's say yeah let's
say for argument's sake that you're
wrong let's just imagine in another
world that you might be okay
hypothetical you can drink way more
Fanta than you can eat Snickers I
believe that which would mean now you're
on my level now you're rocking no but it
means that you can fit it in your body
it doesn't mean that it's not going to
like impact no because calorie is a unit
of measurement for how much energy it
takes to digest something I think it
takes more to digest the Snickers or a
loaf of bread than a [ __ ] liquid I
pee that out you hey hey body hey body
don't even digest it how about that in
out orange stuff don't even digest I'm
not asking for you to digest it I don't
want no energy from this the most ideal
way to drink some [ __ ] is get that
flavor and then pee it out with the
bubbles
I'm cool with the most dominated yes
still carbonated I don't want that as
calories I just want the flavor I you
cannot convince me right now
that 200 calories of bread is the same
as 200 calories of Coca-Cola
I know for a fact it's not okay and
nobody will nobody will uh do whatever
if you get diabetes in three years time
everyone's gonna know where it came from
let me ask you this
right
if calories are the same no matter what
why is it that Atkins works or keto
works
because it is significantly easier to
feel full
from
car from a protein and fat than it is
from carbs carbs cause you to eat more
carbs cause you to eat more correct I
get Fuller way quicker with carbs
immediately that's my point so when you
get no sorry yeah it is you will feel
more satiated from protein than you will
do from over a long period of time but
the immediate fullness comes from carbs
true but you also have you starting to
get on my side [ __ ] it you're starting
to get them I'm just saying liquid
there are there are dietitians like
committing what's that [ __ ] thing
seppuku now in the [ __ ] comments yeah
that thing whatever it is Japanese yeah
anime yeah they're doing that where they
kill themselves yeah that's it yeah
that's what they're doing they're soft
Mr Beast yeah what'd you learn from Mr
Beast because I'm kind of everything but
I'm kind of like
Amazed by him because I can't work out
whether it's work rate or creativity or
like openness to trying new things or
attention to detail and then I watched a
vlog the other day that says he
basically lives in the factory that he
bought that has all of his different
studios in so he's obviously super
committed super committed what'd you
learn from Mr Beast
um how to run a brothel a lot of people
don't know that about him but okay [ __ ]
loves like you know how he's like big on
the hamburgers that's not the only meat
that he's slanging bro this guy sells
bodies man like men and women just
Gigolos and hookers like he's an equal
opportunity he's very equal 100
everybody's allowed but loves selling
sex big into it okay yeah so that's yeah
that's how that's how imagine the
production quality of Mr BEAST's only
fans
oh you got to see it in person bro we'll
go to North Carolina [ __ ] 6K 3D VR
dude yeah what should be up on say again
if you ever watch VR porn no because
I've had sex before yeah well yeah yeah
look I advise you in real life I advise
I advise doing it doing it once just so
that you can see the future [ __ ]
demise of this civilization why is that
good well it's like this it's like there
yeah it's like [ __ ] yeah like right
there yeah yeah yeah it's like pretty
terrifying yeah or yeah I don't know I'm
not a big porn guy but to be honest Mr
abuse is the [ __ ] goat and like
the way that he's I mean just everything
and he's also very gracious with
information like he's shares non-stop
like you can ask him for assistance on
things and he's like yeah do this do
that blah blah blah and uh he's just
he's just great his whole team is great
I mean Tariq is great like all those
guys are [ __ ] awesome they analyze
the hell out of what makes videos work
for attention on YouTube and then they
create those things and it's just
yeah he's [ __ ] I can't say enough
great things about outside of the the
hookers thing that he loves yep slinging
dick yeah yeah it seems to me like dude
big dick dude how much full skin bro you
know he doesn't like foreskin that's
another thing okay he doesn't he like uh
what he'll do is he'll bread them and
make like calamari out of him so like he
has this cool rest that's the new
restaurant that he's made where he has
breaded foreskins and then he sells him
his columns Beast skin yeah be skin be
skin yeah it's crazy that you know that
how do you know that uh uh I saw the
trademark got yeah issued online uh but
outside of that like selling parts of
dick like baby dick at that
he's a great guy how many calories are
in baby dick honestly dude
I don't believe in baby dick calories
either to be honest to be completely
honest with you dude I don't believe in
it full skin calories yeah unreal
calories yeah I don't know I don't know
I don't know I'll have to ask yeah you
could imagine a world in which Mr Beast
using like analytics and this sort of
reverse engineering what do we know that
works and I spend 10 grand on a
thumbnail and I do this stuff to end up
with quite a formulaic and like stodgy
feeling
production yep but it doesn't still it
just feels on changing it but it still
feels like creative and open and fluid
and stuff like that
um that seems pretty like almost
impossible to do oh it seems like the
the balance that is very difficult to
strike of course because there's a bunch
of YouTubers that can make the formulaic
like this is my process and this is how
it will work and I'll rinse and repeat
but then to do that which you know works
and then keep it fresh success is
seductive it's very hard to move away
from success and guaranteed success is a
thing that you've already been doing
very well so him doing a new type of
video or a new genre a new platform
actually creates longevity right like
but at the same time it's dangerous you
know it's a dangerous thing to do he
could flop and when he flops it's big
think about like Hollywood won't even
make a new movie
we're on Mission Impossible nine like
that's you know what I'm saying like
there's no new movies because they're
worried about the amount of money that
they're spending not being returned to
them and uh so that's why I like yeah I
got a lot of respect for for Jimmy and
the boys man a good example of that with
your stuff you decide to do a new style
of Comedy online which is like direct to
camera you start to see some success
with that
is it difficult for you to then say I
need to kind of let this go you have
proof you have that palm of your [ __ ]
hand on YouTube Studio on the analytics
proof yeah shows are selling out better
everything's going better
and now I'm what I'm gonna let that go
I'm gonna stop doing the thing that I
just found yeah that works to do another
new thing which I don't know works yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] exciting so also
like
the time didn't call for it like I'll
bring that back or when I say I will
bring that back like because all the
guys work on it you know it was those
those those [ __ ] rants were were
amazing I mean yeah that was just an
awesome time you know Mark and I started
writing them then we brought in a guy
named Robbie slovick who works for Jon
Stewart now but he's so [ __ ]
brilliant we would write these like
literal essays and then turn them into
jokes and it was it took so much [ __ ]
time it was unbelievable the amount of
time it took to make those miles would
make these images and it was it was
great but um the time needed it like
culturally we needed that I remember I
got sent a
Bill Maher video about uh he did a rant
about the the why it's not racist to
call it the Chinese virus and then he
gave all these exam West Niles from West
Nile Long Island and this is from this
and this this is just what we do and he
um and I got sent that same video by my
uh my wife's stepfather by my brother
by my youngest employee it was like
multiple generations of people were
sending me the same thing and I was like
oh
there's a lack of a voice for honesty
right now and people are craving it and
if we can just get the thing right and
be truthful then it will have eyeballs
and then what we inserted to it were
jokes that you've never seen like a
level of harshness with the jokes that
you just have never seen with topical
stuff like their no network would be
okay with those jokes but the point was
also something that was sliced so thin
you've never seen that so it was like
this combination of like
an intellectual take that was empathetic
to potentially what both sides were
feeling about an issue and what we
believed to be was like the truest
version of that issue
with the harshest jokes you've ever seen
and it was great because we're at this
time we're like nobody believed anything
and I think now we're so desensitized
from like being told one thing and then
it ended up being fake for like three
years in a row I think people have just
checked out so right now is not the time
to do that but eventually like you know
who knows you know presidential race
comes up
we might get back into it you never know
but right now everybody just wants to
disassociate even the drugs people are
using it's like ketamine's popular right
now it's not cocaine cocaine is like I'm
in what are we doing ketamine is like
I'm an observer everything is
disassociation so when people want to
move themselves
you don't want to go all in on what the
issue is and the right thing about it in
my opinion that's very interesting to
take the whatever the cultural milieu
and then go reverse engineer your type
of content
I wonder because it wasn't long ago it
was only three and a half years ago
where you weren't selling out every show
yep uh where you were known but not the
sort of size of platform that you have
now and I'm fascinated by people who are
kind of on a trajectory from
not super famous to getting pretty
[ __ ] famous
what have you learned about
what's changed like what about the
Perils of fame or or the challenges
I'm not saying I'm famous but having
some level of like Fame notoriety yeah
it is what I love about it is people
trust your kindness
and I'm genuinely like a kind person
like I can be nice to somebody and they
don't think I want something from them
because I'm probably the more famous
person in that interaction oh so when I
walk in a restaurant and I'm nice to
like the host or the waiter they're
going holy [ __ ] this guy that I watch
all this comedy he's like really like a
nice guy as opposed to because he wants
a freak
if they want a better seat like I'm not
using kindness as a weapon or tool to
extract anything from you I'm just
giving you kindness so it's allowed me
to be like the person who I always want
to be I grew up in New York which is
like we don't trust kindness like if you
were nice to me and I don't know you I
think you want something from me because
that's how people do it in New York
right they come up to hey man how's your
day do you have a little moment for uh
the climate and it's like oh you were
you use niceness to get money out of me
so it's great for a guy like me I didn't
grow up in a small town where
everybody's nice to one another I grew
up in a town where kindness is
specifically used as a tool to
manipulate and remove money that is the
goal of kindness in New York
that's why in New York we were like
roasty with one another because that's
how I know that you're safe
you know what I'm saying why would it be
the case that someone who didn't roast
back wouldn't be safe because they would
be overplaying the nice hand in an
attempt to try and get well not even
Rose back like if the first thing you do
is you make fun of an environment you do
something like that you walk into my
store or something like that like and
you're like uh
um you know I don't know I'm trying to
think like you walk into your store and
it's like uh you know someone just
robbed this place or whatever some
[ __ ] joke you're insulting the store
now the guy on some level is going
okay he's insulting me that's bad but at
the same time he's not trying to
manipulate me that's also good I can
trust this guy's intentions potentially
that might not be the best example but
one of the coolest things about having
Fame is just being able to be nice to
people and them like appreciating also
um and this is a um a Norm Macdonald
line but I agree with this completely
it's like you get the best version of
people like people come up to you with a
smile they come up to you happy they
come up to you excited like you're
getting like this awesome treatment from
people you're most people walk around
the streets they're upset they're
stressed about something they gotta go
somewhere they're in a rush they got no
time for anybody they're bumping into
you
most of the interactions I get to have
is people going hey I love what you do
you're really proud of this thing and I
love what you do and my specific type of
like uh I hate using these types of
words but like notoriety is like they
know me for being myself I'm not playing
Superman Gladiator or some [ __ ] yeah
like where you really like Superman you
don't like me you like the character I
play he's like yeah this is me these are
the things I think the things I feel so
you appreciating that is so fulfilling
so it is it is awesome and I'm not at
that level I guess where it ruins your
life but I also think that's a choice
like I'm not gonna name names but like I
have people I see rolling around with
like [ __ ] 100 security guards and
[ __ ] and all of a sudden I'm just like
I've been with people who have security
guards and nobody recognizes them they
just recognize me
I think you're over playing
this situation now I don't want to jinx
myself somebody comes up and robs me or
something but have you considered what
happens if you overshoot Fame what does
overshoot mean so there's an article
called 13 reasons not to get famous by
Tim Ferriss he wrote it probably about
six or seven years ago and it's one of
the [ __ ] best things that I've ever
read most people in the world are below
the level of Fame that they would like
to get to even you maybe even you would
like as someone that's got a pretty big
platform to continue to accumulate more
notoriety I never think about Fame ah
not for its own sake yeah but like it
comes as a byproduct of doing more
things success right yes great it would
it would be unlikely for you to say I'm
prepared to stop doing what I'm doing
because I now have too much Fame that
might be a better way to frame it like
you would stop doing the podcast because
if you accumulate one more subscriber
that would be one too many that may know
you that the byproduct of what you're
doing would cause you like discomfort
with Fame so my point being that almost
everybody in the world has less fame or
notoriety than they would be comfortable
with having yeah right you don't know
that threshold until you pass it and you
can't stop it you can't stop it once it
happens and Tim Ferriss Tim Ferriss is
one of these guys who blasted through
this ceiling yeah and he uses it's these
13 Reasons and this guy
camps up outside of the house that he's
living in maybe in Austin a long time
ago now uh and lives outside on his
front lawn for like two weeks yeah
because he's adamant that Tim is sending
him secret messages in his podcast
saying he wants to be in a relationship
with him and Tim has to check into every
hotel that he goes on holiday with under
a pseudonym under a fake name yeah
because people find out they call all of
the hotels in the area not able to
upload Family Photos when he's been
going away and all sorts of stuff he
never puts photos of like his friends
and the people that he's with and all
this sort of [ __ ] like he never does any
of that
um and he says like these are some of
the prices that you pay in order to get
the level of Fame I think he had maybe
like a 700 million to one billion person
audience like the number of not
obviously individual people but the
number of exposures and he was like
million to one odds happen eight times a
day in New York
if you have an audience of let's say 100
million people yeah let's say there's
100 million people that know who you are
and know what you do one percent of the
world of psychopaths of that one percent
let's say that one percent of them have
sufficient motivation to come and do
something and like one percent of them
have got [ __ ] you're like you're
still left with a pretty significant
cohort of people that when you broaden
out the amount of people that know you
yeah I was at the Onyx gym
in Austin and some dude came in with
this like sort of scraggly shuffly
looking guy out of his car with this
handwritten [ __ ] like ring binder
thing and put it down and said I need to
speak to Aubrey Marcus owner of on it so
you have on it they're like
he doesn't like he didn't work he don't
need to sell the company to Unilever
like six months ago but like he did he's
not here he doesn't live and work in
here yeah and he's like okay I'll wait
in the car and they were like no you
don't understand like he's not here he's
not coming here he's like I need to
speak to Aubrey I need to give him this
yeah my point being that when you start
an Aubrey's audience is like you know
comparable with the size of of mine
yeah yeah the the first of all I
couldn't pick Tim Ferriss out of a
lineup to save my wife's life
I have no [ __ ] clue what that guy
looks like
I don't think that he has an issue
walking around at all I can't believe
that at all uh that's not to say that
people don't know him but I just know
[ __ ] clue what he looks like I know
who he is the five hour work week guy or
whatever you know
um one of those just went inject that
one of the reasons for that is he's
significantly backed off his public
Persona over the last decade gotcha he
had a show on uh Discovery or something
yeah I bought his book too I got the the
perfect example of what you said though
is you want everybody to know your name
and nobody to know your face if you want
to maximize your yeah I mean it depends
but then you don't get the that like
amazing treatment precisely critical and
then they can't trust the kindness that
you give them and that kind of stuff so
I I think with Tim Ferriss the problem
is you have to figure out like what Lane
you're in if you're in self-help you're
gonna attract the people that need the
most help
a guy willing to camp out on your
[ __ ] lawn needs a lot of help so I'm
not surprised that the self-help people
get the weirdest craziest [ __ ]
followers that do all the weird crazy
[ __ ] I'm a comedian I like making sane
people laugh that is the fun thing for
me right and I like poking fun at
absolutely everybody I'm not saying I
don't say I'm some [ __ ] important guy
I don't even go say comedy is important
I say treat us with the least level of
respect the the less respect you have
for us the better there's so many Comics
who out there like we're the modern day
philosophers I'm sure I've said this on
some [ __ ] podcast that I'm a modern
day and I regret ever saying it I regret
ever giving any kind of importance to
Comedy because then you can't say
anything you can't say we're the modern
day philosophers we're the ones putting
the truth truth out there in the world
we're the ones changing the world we're
the ones holding the mirror up to the
[ __ ] powerful people
and then on the same level go why are
they canceling us for what we say you
said you're important you said you're
changing the world well if I was someone
in power I'd sure want to silence those
[ __ ] that are saying the real
[ __ ] if you're that important say we're
not important at all and we could say
whatever the [ __ ] we want I value saying
what the [ __ ] I want so treat me like a
clown I don't give a [ __ ] I wonder if
that's part of the problem that Brian
had
which is that he's been he's done
serious stuff he's done serious stuff of
course and then when you want to get out
of jail free card I was just making a
joke like
it's very difficult to do that yeah man
well I'd be very interested to to track
it with Ferris I don't I don't know
don't get me wrong there it gets a level
like I see what certain like ones and my
friends have to go through that is like
very [ __ ] difficult and it's not only
difficult in regards like how your life
is because like listen I I you know my
wife will get [ __ ] uh insulted and
that kind of stuff on the line and like
when you when you have a wife and you
have children you're subjecting your
family to this [ __ ] too you know I was
talking to Patrick Dave on the podcast
and I was like would you run for
governor he's like no I wouldn't subject
my family just for governor he goes for
president it might be worth it like but
for governor now he's making a value
judgment between what's the price I pay
versus what's the return that I get 100
yeah it'll be interesting man I mean one
of the problems that you definitely do
have is you you've got friends who for
whom you were I think about to say it
that it affects the people around them
like if you want to go out for dinner
with Joe it's like we need to pre-vet
the place that we're going he needs to
have these guys it needs to be a closed
up room because it's just going to be
bing bing throughout the entire night
okay so how do you maintain your
normalcy in that I'm like I'm so lucky
everything I do is collaborative and
it's one of the things I've realized in
life I love I love doing things with the
people that I cherish I love spending
time to camaraderie it's all about
everything that I do I know when I'm up
on stage I'm I'm just beat me by myself
right but if you even notice like how I
do stand up I'm like curious about the
people there as well like I'm
interactive with them even with the
jokes that I've like pre-written and
these pieces I'm still like there's this
conversation because I like being with
people and I like I like creating with
people right those are the things I like
I don't want it just to be me I like
having this group and we solve these
problems together for me that is the
most awesome thing like I even look at
the movies that I love like Ocean's 11
is just like to me the best movie
because it's 11 Misfits that come
together to solve this impossible
problem right like this is a metaphor
for for our lives so one of the things I
like about that is that I'm coming up
like Dove who's my manager producing
partner I my first friend in college
Jamil he met out there was my best
friend since I'm 13 years old right like
icons my first friend in comedy like all
these people that are part of the team
and Mark and Miles went to college
together like all these people are part
of the team and the part of these people
that we enjoy hanging out and working
together because that is the most fun
for me and it also maintains a level of
normalcy if you're isolated you're by
yourself you're the only one doing this
the bigger this thing gets who's your
boy who's just making funny
who's your boy that's just gonna keep
you humble who's your boy that's going
to let you know what you're doing is
absolutely great and you can trust that
is the something special about it being
a member of the team or an inside person
that's a part of the project as opposed
to it just being a friend that you have
that's been with you the whole time well
I also have those guys you know is there
something extra that you get from the
guys that you work with I like getting
money with my boys I'm gonna be honest
with you that makes me happy like on the
come up together yeah like because these
are things we talked about like I
remember when Jamil was working over a
TripAdvisor I was like yo one day we're
gonna do the ads together for for the
pot and then for other parts we're going
to build an app and TripAdvisor will be
the one that comes to us right and then
like now we're doing it so it's cool to
like imagine these things and then like
live them out like I'm dude when me and
Dove were in college we almost did a
radio show together how crazy is this
now he is managing basically radiation a
[ __ ] radio you know like all these
things we planned and then we're
executing that to me is fun like seeing
your friends buy some expensive [ __ ]
from the money you guys made together
seeing your friends like treat their
[ __ ] wives right you buy something
he's got a very very fast BMW back in
the UK in that fire [ __ ] unreal man
Isn't that cool one of the [ __ ]
coolest things that's happened since
doing the show is the ability to like
liberate good other people that have
come along with me like the first year
that we did the show he made
50 pounds probably in AdSense yeah we've
split YouTube down the middle since we
very very first started yeah
um he worked for worse than free
whatever worse than free is yeah yeah
for like two and a half years yeah and
then [ __ ] by year four he's got
I'm like let's [ __ ] go that's I mean
to me that's just the most beautiful let
me give you the other one let me give
you the second thing that for me so
that's one of them
for a long time when you're doing a show
especially mine where the come-up's been
like pretty gradual like took a long
time to get to anything and now it's
really taking off you're like slip
streaming the clout of everybody else
right I'm holding on to the coattails of
Douglas Murray or Jordan Peterson no
[ __ ] whoever right yeah and then
after a little bit of time you get
sufficient momentum that you realize
that you can be that springboard for
other people yeah you got clout and
you're like oh holy [ __ ] I get to go and
find some underground hero yeah that is
way more brilliant than the amount of
people that know about them
and then give them a platform and they
[ __ ] away they go Louise Perry wrote
this amazing book called the case
against the sexual Revolution I release
an episode and so does trigonometry and
it goes to number one on Amazon like
because she F because she's brilliant
yeah and we happen to have the platform
that was able to display her brother
absolutely and it's just rinse and
repeat now that's [ __ ] cool oh it's
awesome I [ __ ] love doing that
especially if you really admire those
people you really love them or they
deserve a fair shot it's great using
your platform in that way a hundred
percent I agree with you and that's what
I admire so much about Joe to be honest
it's like
yeah Joe's this [ __ ] man he's literally
he is is cool even if you're a fan as
cool as you think he is you don't really
understand what he did because like when
he puts a guy like me on his podcast
that could bomb you know how many Comics
he'll put on and I'm sure the episodes
don't do as well but he's doing because
those people are hilarious and he feels
that people should see them most people
when they get power they don't like to
give it away like George is on some like
I mean I mean that Joe's on something
like George Washington [ __ ] like it's
crazy to to to be president and be like
all right I gotta stop this
you know what I mean like I Gotta Give
power back to the people that's a weird
thing to [ __ ] Marcus Aurelius
philosopher king [ __ ] low-key low-key so
it's like
yeah it's it's just a benevolent a
benevolent King is the rarest one and we
got it and we gotta appreciate it while
while it's it's here because it's not
always going to be here because usually
what the thing inside people that makes
them want to get power is the thing that
will make them not want to relinquish
any of it correct yeah I mean you're
totally right I never even thought of it
but there could be another world in
which the biggest podcaster in the world
also happened to be a total [ __ ] that
will be the case most likely at some
point after Joe retires
forever yeah like like this is the
anomaly yeah you know what I mean like I
I honestly it's so weird and that's so
that's kind of like every you know
everybody has your North Stars like my
father's my North Star in like most
situations like I'm just like what would
he do like how would he treat the people
around him how would he Empower them how
would he do that [ __ ] and I look at
other people that also do that and I'm
like you know he's a great example
especially in the entertainment business
about how you could put people on yeah
and how you could put people on and that
doesn't hurt you that just makes you
that much better like Loki I look at
Drake like that too like Drake gave so
many people features and then made them
famous because of those features that
didn't make Drake any less but what it
did do is made every one of those
artists so grateful of Drake
so now
anytime Drake needs anything they're
there any anybody says anything about
Drake they're like nah [ __ ] you that guy
made me a millionaire yeah my mom a
house yeah like he didn't have to simply
because he loved my art how he's done
his career how Joe's it's also no
[ __ ]
yeah it's it's it's it's not surprising
at all that you look at the people that
are at the top of their careers or like
their top of their Industries and
they're operating in a kind of similar
way which is who like point I'm just
saying Drake and Rogan like yes pointing
out these people who are far less famous
and successful than them and then giving
them the platform to be successful Drake
Will Go On Your Song
he's not even saying be on my [ __ ] he's
going I'm going on your [ __ ]
you know what I mean like that's crazy
like I asked Jose yo will you be the
first guest on the Pod he's like
absolutely yeah
and you never want to ask somebody you
know is that busy but it was one of
those things where it's like we also
want to kind of honor him a little bit
you know what I mean it's like I think
it's only like a shrine yeah like yo man
like you're so instrumental in even
making this so that's the thing like I
think that's why also there's so many
people that'll defend Joe no matter what
what anybody says about him this was the
interesting thing that I realized around
a bunch of the different controversies
that happened over the last year with
him
what happens usually when the Press
brings up a particular news story is
they say this is the tip of the iceberg
that shows this particular person is the
homophobic racist transphobic
misogynistic piece of [ __ ] that we've
always said that there were yeah now the
problem with Joe for the Press was even
a casual fan has listened to like 200 to
500 hours and there's people that have
listened to multiple thousands of hours
and they go yeah you're telling us that
this is the tip of the iceberg
I've seen the whole Iceberg yeah I know
that there's nothing down there exactly
so for you to
besmirch and like smear this person's
name by claiming you know something I
don't yeah I don't think you do yeah
yeah that's what that's what was so I
think what is so good it's such a good
protectionist strategy and it's not a
strategy but it's just a byproduct of
talking for hundreds and hundreds of
hours every single year it's like look
if I [ __ ] genuinely didn't like black
people yeah it would be out there by now
people would know how [ __ ] good of an
actor do you think I am yeah to be able
to hold this non-racist persona for like
[ __ ] thousands and thousands of hours
yeah and the craziest thing is he's
vegan that's the thing a lot of people
don't know like that elk [ __ ] is a lie
like Beyond elk it's beyond elk it's
he's he's a very strict vegan like
strict vegan and can't use a crossbow
for [ __ ] I was like yo show me how to do
that bow and arrow [ __ ] tiny foreskin
dude can't crossbow those are the things
you gotta attack them for those are the
every one of those is CGI the crossbow
[ __ ] CGI like he uses he takes a scooter
to work like a Razor scooter to work
he's just doing like every single day
that's I don't know why they don't
attack him for that they always come for
these old videos and that kind of stuff
but you got a vegan on a Razor scooter
that can't even use a crossbro you know
like that's the thing that you should
probably write a New York Times article
about you know isn't that crazy like
when you go you know how you've done the
Pod and he's just like you know mashing
down Beyond Burgers like he's like this
is soy like you know how he tries to rub
soy on your tits right before every pot
like that's that's my favorite part I'm
gonna wipe it off the microphone before
you again yeah yeah [ __ ] dude I I uh
now he's a [ __ ] man dude I think it's
very
scary what happens if if and when he
like bows out and somebody else comes
through same thing that happened in L.A
like look at the LA comedy scene when he
was at the helm of L.A Comics everybody
was helping each other out it was this
like beautiful camaraderie that was
happening what's it like now well one I
you know not as many people going out to
the shows and that's reasonable because
you have the most famous person on the
planet that's gonna go to the the comedy
clubs every single week so naturally
you're gonna have people come out there
but
um but yeah just uh it doesn't feel like
there's that same energy that same
excitement that same camaraderie that
was there and I think naturally things
can get a little bit more competitive
people are organizing who's the next
king who's the next person what's the
power vacuum so there's a power grab
happening of course and uh
but yeah man it's like
yeah that that that potentially can
happen you gotta hope that a guy like
that has instilled enough values in
people that even if they are like these
kind of psychopaths they see that the
way to success is through altruism
kindness support and you've left behind
this like tradition almost yeah so even
though they're using it they're doing
those things for the wrong reason
like it's like even though they they
just being a Christian so they could get
to heaven at least they're being a
Christian moscow's wager again yes
exactly yes you got it right Papa loves
away Papa's wager I always [ __ ] it up
all right so think about for me we're
talking about this sort of change of
status and note right if you and you
mentioned earlier on that you and your
new wife are now starting to try for
kids yep right
comedians are used to being grafters
right you do all of these shows and
you've got this podcast and you do this
stuff online and all the rest of it yeah
are you is there a tension between the
amount of work that you want to do and
how much you're used to doing and the
fact that that's got you a particular
level of success and the fact that
moving forward you're not going to be
able to serve yourself in the same sort
of selfish way
anymore you're now going to have to let
go of some of the strategies that got
you to where you are if you want to
become the husband and father and family
Builder that you're 100 yeah 100 yeah
you have to
that's why for me it's like I want to
learn how to be like a businessman
like I'm good at making money but that's
not because I'm ever chasing money it
says I'm chasing greatness and I'm I'm
good at recognizing Talent like the guys
that [ __ ] work with me all those guys
are goddamn Superstars and it's like but
I want to learn how to run a business so
that I can create free time because
right now I'm the bottleneck for all my
time correct you know so it's like but
what if I learned how to do it like a
real businessman would do or brought in
somebody you know that could teach me
how to run it so I can create more
pockets of time for myself because to me
yeah that will be the most important
thing you know obviously starting a
family and wanting to make time to spend
time with them specifically and like
honestly go through those life changes
and see how that's reflected in the work
as well I'm excited for that I'm done
talking about the same [ __ ] I've already
talked about doing dad jokes yeah I
can't wait for Dad I can't wait to talk
about family like because the people who
listen to me are also going through that
correct they're also having families
right they're also married they're also
experiencing these things I like
evolving with them like I don't want to
be like a clothing brand that's still
trying to sell [ __ ] to 16 year olds in
your 55 like [ __ ] that like I want to
grow with them and I want those 16 year
olds that listen to Google like oh [ __ ]
that's what's going to be like comes
along for the ride I listen to [ __ ]
Chris Rock when he was probably in his I
mean I don't know how old he is but like
I know I was a teen and I'm listening to
this older guy talk about relationships
and that kind of stuff that I wasn't
exactly relating to but I recognized how
funny he was
so I think that's there but but yeah man
to me that's that is the greatest
honor you know like building that family
and trying to instill some cool values
in a kid I have a friend who has made a
good bit of money throughout his 20s off
the back of really really great products
and courses that he released online and
he's got this new girlfriend and he's
all [ __ ] smitten with her and they've
been together for maybe a year or so now
we went out for dinner not long ago and
we were just chatting about sort of
where he's at and the journey he's got
to to get himself to the level of
success he's at now and he was like you
know what it is man I realized that most
of my 20s were spent setting me up to be
the dad that I want to be for my future
kids that's cool I was like that's
[ __ ] dope yeah so [ __ ] cool yeah
and you realize that you know the strife
and the challenges and the
overcomingness and the learning and all
of that you know it's nice to give it
away to people and they resonate with
you and you're like that's [ __ ]
brilliant but imagine if I synthesized
it down and focused it on like [ __ ]
three tiny little humans that had my
genetics 100 that's [ __ ] cool that's
awesome yeah I think that's way that
that's the ultimate success like I think
that's the ultimate thing that I'll be
defined as you know for me at least I've
been very fortunate that like I've
achieved there's like one more goal I
have in stand-up and then I've checked
off you say what it is yeah I just want
to sell at Madison Square run how many
people is that uh there's different ways
to do it but I think in the center
and I have to make sure that's the best
show that's like 18 000 and then if off
to the side it's like 12 000. so there
was like it was one of these things
where like for the last tour I was like
do we do it for the last tour because we
did Radio City that's just six thousand
but we did that twice so that's twelve
thousand like all right maybe we could
have done that and check it off but then
there's also the big boy there's 18
maybe you want to get that so that's the
last that's the last goal that's not to
say that I'm gonna stop I think I'll
have plenty new goals but of those older
ones
that's the one where I'm like okay I
still want to I still want to check that
off but it's funny like success will
make you value completely different
things man like
I don't know I I was like I would look
for inspiration in terms of
I look for inspiration in terms of the
things that like man has created like I
went out there and I was I I you know I
look at the pyramids I look at Rome I
look at Paris look at Tokyo like I was
going around to all like the greatest
Creations that you know man is
responsible for right and I'm like oh
this is really inspiring and then I was
out in like Utah and I looked at you
know what time has created you know what
I mean like you see a [ __ ] Canyon
that was created over 100 million years
and
one it's like absolutely beautiful but
two it puts things in perspective like
how short a time we have here and like
what we're gonna do with this time I
think that's why I like bust David
Gaga's balls a little bit it's like okay
you spend your time running that's
awesome you know but like how do I want
to spend my time
do I want to spend it creating yes I
love creating do I want to spend it
developing this relationship and this
partnership with my wife yes I want to
do that do I want to raise these kids
and I want to experience things with
these kids and through these kids and
hopefully prepare them for the world
which is [ __ ] terrifying like the
[ __ ] do I know about the world you know
I know about some stand-up comedy I'm
not going to have the right thing to say
when they're having a tough issue at
school who do I call my dad and ask the
right thing to say is there a book I can
read you know that's another thing it's
like how do I want to process my time
here and I think that's what I'm
thinking about and it's very likely I'll
get to like a dollar amount where I just
where I might I know I might stop
everything I might get into a dollar
amount I'm like okay that's it I'm done
with everything I'm just gonna focus
with my kids enjoy the [ __ ] out of life
with my kids and travel with my wife and
make sure I experience every little
thing I want to make sure she gets
experience every little thing in the
world that she wants to that's that's
completely possible
or I might do that and then realize wow
I really love creating it's fulfilling
and like having these conversations is
like so important to me and I'm not
doing it for money because I have enough
money to say [ __ ] you I'm doing it just
because I truly love it like
yeah we'll have to cross that bridge and
get there but I want to at the end of
the day be like I got the most out of
this [ __ ] time like if I get 100
years on this planet I want to feel at
the end of it I was like I was like yep
I did that right I had some [ __ ]
dessert I ate some bread not too much I
did enough running and exercise stayed
healthy you know I was a hell of a
[ __ ] husband you know I was I I hope
to God you know as if I could be half as
good a dad to my kids as my dad was to
me that would be that would be
incredible
um
a good son like that
yeah that type of [ __ ] is is where I'll
Define
myself and hopefully get to a point
where
I'm not trying to
I'm not trying to keep myself busy and
distracted and more at peace with all
this great stuff that's happening
um you know what I mean when it comes to
the business side of stuff uh it's
interesting to think about what you're
building here and Tom Segura as well in
your mom's house he's like a really
[ __ ] good example he's a brilliant
man yeah
it's a miniature Production Studio yeah
it's like it's a genuine Production
Studio and given the fact that recently
you already
what was New Media streaming
took back control from something that
already felt like New Media so like new
New Media yeah
and then there's another one from that
which is like no [ __ ] you this is mine
now this is independent creation
director customer direct to Consumer
yeah what what do you think because
obviously you've got the inside of
Hollywood thing you were back over in
the UK doing some acting I think at some
point not just too long ago a few movies
so if that's the case you you're
straddling both sides right you're
seeing still the old world yeah and
you're also slap bang in the middle of
the new world yeah yeah what what's your
predictions for the next five to ten
years for so for for me it's like I like
the institutions that are built I don't
want to like create a new streaming
platform that's not my goal like we'll
use the the platforms that exist already
I want to focus on creating things and
whether they live on YouTube or they
live on Netflix or Amazon or any of
these places or movie theaters that's
that's awesome but I just want to make
sure I'm doing the most creating we had
to build out a business you know
apparatus in order to like execute the
dreams because we didn't have the
opportunity on these traditional
channels so like I had to put out to put
on the business hat that I didn't really
necessarily want to but but I had to
because I want to find a way to solve
problems and get what I want but um I
think in the future at least for me I
really want to make a film that's why
I'm doing this acting stuff now so I can
like see what the process is you know
and it's like but I really want to make
a film because I'm really obsessed with
story and I think story is the
like the key to information like the
truest way that we digest and hold
information and huberman said a really
interesting interesting thing I was like
yo tell me about story like what's going
on with story and he goes uh he goes
here I don't know what the [ __ ] it is
about stories but
um even when I quote people I make them
sound Dumber uh but I don't know what
the [ __ ] it is a doctor right but no no
but uh he goes uh when somebody's
telling a story their heart rate no
sorry the people who are listening their
heart rates all change at the same time
and I was like oh there it is and that's
like stories stories are like music like
the reaction is music right and it's
like you can capture attention you can
convey information like the greatest
politicians answer every question of the
story correct you know love them or hate
them like Bill Clinton when he answers
the question it's always ah you know one
time in South Carolina we are doing this
and then climate change and then wow
that was awesome I'll never forget that
right so it's like
one how do we tell a story
you know and and really Master the art
of that and two how do we use the tools
from a story to really execute the
things that that I feel the guys feel
you know things that people come across
yeah I thought when I first started the
show because I was part of like the
productivity space at least in the very
first instance and I was pretty adamant
that the way to make a good podcast was
to like ruthlessly index information as
succinctly as possible and what I wanted
was you Andrew cubeman me host me
dissect brain take information give it
to audience and over time I've realized
that you're a Vibe architect like your
job is to architect A vibe for people
and it's not about ruthlessly getting
information out there maybe they'll take
some stuff away but there is absolutely
no chance that someone isn't going to be
able to remember the short girl going
around the corner of the supermarket and
seeing like this like [ __ ] little
[ __ ] with the tall guy in the front
like what does that tell you oh well
maybe they'll remember intersexual
competition or some other stuff but if
you convey that through a story it hits
so much harder and it took me so long to
realize that because it's kind of scary
it feels almost like a low ball effort
or like I know like basic or I don't
know I I just didn't have faith in
stories yeah and it's only been within
the last probably 18 months where I've
gone oh we need to lean into this more
it's biological yeah it's it's I don't
know why anybody goes away that I've
gone away through it as well I'm like
what is the point that I'm trying to do
even with jokes you're like here's
premise and here's a punch line execute
it it's like how is this how can we turn
this into you know a story I mean
there's this bit in my special I do this
abortion bit and uh it was basically
three different bits that I turned into
a story and the most fascinating thing
that about it is that when I'm telling
it I believe that that happened
like it didn't happen like that these
are three individual things that I
thought were funny and then I blend them
to story and I can even convince myself
that this happened like as I'm telling
it I'm remembering being at a specific
Street and seeing a specific person that
did not happen
if I can do that with me imagine what a
story can do with somebody else right so
it's like yeah I would love to tell
yeah I wanna I wanna make a film man I
want to make a film at least yeah maybe
we'll start with one but then others and
I think right now it's it's the time for
a rated R film and and to answer your
initial question like how we're going to
straddle that like New Media and new New
Media is I think that if you're going to
make anything transformative you have to
do it independently and then once you
prove the product it's worth it for
those people who are worried about
losing their jobs to take that chance
it's not initially and that's why you'll
never make a rated R comedy I'll trade
it on uh like um rated R is like um it
goes PG-13 rated they go G is like a
cartoons PG-13 is you gotta be 13 to buy
a ticket and then rated R's you got to
be I think like 18 to buy a ticket
attention so it's adult content okay I
think the hangover is probably rated R
like the the funnier comedies and um but
there hasn't been a rated R comedy that
was hilarious in probably two decades
it's kind of crazy even think about
maybe 15 years like if if we if we
literally think back like what was that
hilarious movie I saw recently
like think about that this is like
that's crazy so and the reason is what I
was telling you before right it's just
like people are worried about losing
their jobs and it's not that Hollywood
has necessarily this like huge liberal
slant it's just when you're worried
about getting fired you're liberal
when you're worried about getting fired
you are accepting right you walk on your
boss and he's like [ __ ] a dog you're
just like Love Is Love bro you know what
I mean like because what if God forbid
you said something about that and then
your boss was like get the [ __ ] out of
here you're fired so everybody just
leans into that direction now granted
it's California people are more liberal
Etc but it's more of like
self-preservation than anything else I
genuinely feel that way it's like how
can I not lose my [ __ ] job the way
you don't lose your job is if we prove
that this movie can make a quarter
billion dollars without you and then
everybody else out there is going okay
you need to get on that get on that
[ __ ] movie Rory Rory Sutherland one
of my friends smartest behavioral
Economist in the world he said
people would much sooner fail with a
safe strategy than succeed with a risky
one especially if it's not their
business
oh yeah because no one is ever what was
their [ __ ] analogy nobody was ever
fired for uh using JP Morgan
like but people do get fired for using
this brand new bank that's maybe amazing
but maybe not it's like you will always
take the safe option uh speaking of dog
[ __ ] yeah I saw this [ __ ]
Florida demand sexually abused dog
wreaked havoc at nearby church and
attempted to steal a car in a wild
action-packed outing police say around 4
30 PM police received a call about a man
who had allegedly allegedly caused quite
a disturbance in Clearwater neighborhood
according to Witnesses 36 year old Chad
Mason of Orlando was taking a friend's
golden doodle for a walk in an apartment
complex that afternoon when he suddenly
began having sex with the dog in full
view of the public including at least
one child when an adult confronted him
about the act of bestiality Mason ran
off and took refuge in the local
Presbyterian Church he wreaked more
Havoc Witnesses said he appended a
nativity set several potted plants
carving approximately 400 worth of
damage after he left the church Mason
reportedly ran to a nearby neighborhood
where he destroyed a mailbox and
attempted to steal a car Clearwater
Police took him into custody Mason
bonded out of jail and is scheduled to
appear in court sometime later this
month the current condition and
whereabouts of the golden doodle have
not been reported
you know it's real [ __ ] Florida man
that Florida is how we cure uh racism
elaborate
because no matter what race someone is
when they do something crazy in Florida
nobody thinks it's the Race's fault
they're like
oh that's Florida
do you know what I'm saying like like if
if
that was any other race and they went
like Asian man or whatever all the
racists that hate Asians would be like
see that's how they act right but with
Florida we just are prejudiced towards
the whole state so now we just see them
all as equal like anybody can be equally
crazy as long as they're from Florida
it's kind of beautiful
Florida's not really a part of America
right it's like you've got Alaska Hawaii
and Florida and no one really thinks
about them that's actually kind of
interesting what you're saying when you
mention those three places because
they're all versions of America for
people who aren't from there except for
Alaska but like Hawaii is Asian people's
version of America and Miami
specifically is Latin America's version
of America so it's not
America but it is and Hawaii when you're
in there you're like yeah it's America
kinda but it's a little Asian about it
you know like you're not like yeah this
is how home is right there's like a
little part of where you're from that
looks like that but it's not the whole
city you know and I think that's when
you know when you were talking even
earlier about your experience in Miami
when you look at
the the
when you look at like what made Miami
and the culture that defined Miami
you're talking about a lot of people
that are leaving impoverished places and
when you come from no money and get
money you want to show it off yeah and
oftentimes those places that they're
coming from that are impoverished a
woman's value is her looks so to seem
the most valuable or Rich she's going to
accentuate those as much as I saw my
first pbl in Miami it's like a [ __ ]
optical illusion it's like two
basketballs on an upturned baseball bat
it's like pretty [ __ ] awful it's not
gonna look good it's like a bag of cards
yeah yeah
good bag of cats like [ __ ] slopping
around all over the place it's not the
best but I understand like where they're
coming from and why they're doing that
you went to Miami briefly yeah I loved
it but didn't stay no
presumably too happy too happy yeah
what's that mean couldn't write any
jokes and I don't need to be miserable
or depressed to write jokes but there
was nothing for me to push back against
like when my version of Miami wasn't
like the the douchey one that you saw
and I just saw that recently I was there
for our basil and it was [ __ ]
miserable like it was the worst aspects
of Miami squeeze into one weekend but
what I was seeing which is the things I
love about Latin culture which is like a
love of family a love of Celebration and
like partying and it's like what am I
upset about here like I love when the
the girl with [ __ ] purple armpit hair
is complaining about some [ __ ] outside
of a library I like pushing back against
that right in Miami what am I pushing
back against they want to hang out with
their family love each other dance and
listen to music like what is annoying
about that nothing I'm like enjoy your
[ __ ] fam we need some family time we
need to enjoy life regardless if we have
money or we don't have money and we need
to have a little uh party in celebration
so it was it was uh that was tricky but
everything else about life there was
just phenomenal you're just getting
vitamin D every single [ __ ] day it
was just so yeah there are parts of
Miami that I absolutely [ __ ] love man
love love but I don't know if I could
live there full time too enjoyable for
this time of my life
Andrew Schultz ladies and gentlemen
dudes I really appreciate the [ __ ] out
of you thank you for having me my
brother I appreciate you man uh where
should people go and what can they
expect from you soon what have you got
coming up next any cool [ __ ] yeah you
can check out the podcast uh I got some
movies coming out this year so that'll
be pretty cool if I don't get cut out of
them that'd be awesome and then uh yeah
we're gonna the podcast flagrant I do
really need this for Charlemagne I got
my stand-up specials on YouTube right
now it's called Infamous go check that
out and then uh some cool [ __ ] in the
future uh that I won't say exactly just
right now but yeah keep in touch
appreciate you man thank you thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]